My name is Jordan and I'm from Indiana.
我叫乔丹，来自印第安纳州。
Last summer I started my third viewing of how I met your mother.
去年夏天，我开始第三次观看我是如何认识你母亲的。
My first girlfriend had just broken up with me, and the show felt like the only thing that could get me through those first three days.
我的第一个女朋友刚刚和我分手，这部剧感觉是唯一能让我度过前三天的事情。
I remember watching Return of the Shirt very distinctly.
我记得非常清楚地看过《衬衫归来》。
I was practically shouting at Ted the entire episode.
整集我几乎都在对特德大喊大叫。
While the topic hit a little close to home at that point, I realized how interesting it was to be able to view this show with that new perspective, one of someone who had been broken up with.
虽然这个话题当时有点切中要害，但我意识到能够以一种新的视角（一个已经分手的人）来观看这个节目是多么有趣。
I think that's the beauty of this show.
我认为这就是这个节目的美妙之处。
I get something new out of it every single time I watch it.
每次看它我都会从中得到新的东西。
I'll be soon in New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything of city.
我很快就会到纽约市，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你这座城市的一切。
Hello, welcome to how we made your mother.
你好，欢迎来到我们如何创造你的母亲。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am joined as ever by my dear friend and how I met your mother co-creator Craig Thomas.
我亲爱的朋友一如既往地加入了我的行列，以及我如何认识你的母亲共同创造者克雷格·托马斯。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
We're talking about episode four, season one, return of the shirt.
我们正在谈论第一季第四集，衬衫的回归。
This episode aired when, Alec.
这一集播出时，亚历克。
On October 10th, 2005.
2005 年 10 月 10 日。
October 10th, 2005, nearly 20 years ago, it's so long ago, it's so long ago.
2005年10月10日，快20年前了，好久远了，好久远了。
I can't handle it.
我应付不了。
Okay.
好的。
Who do we have joining us today?
今天有谁加入我们？
I'm very excited to have our guest today appropriately enough.
我很高兴今天能以适当的方式邀请我们的客人。
We have the writer of this episode, return the shirt.
我们已经找到了这一集的编剧，请归还衬衫。
In the entire amount of amateur mother, there were only two writers who were there from day one, from the pilot, like the pilot punch up session, right?
在整个业余母亲中，只有两名作家从第一天起就在那里，来自试播集，就像试播集的打孔环节，对吗？
Hired onto the show on the pilot, there are 208 episodes, two writers.
该剧聘请到试播集，共有208集，两位编剧。
Chris Harris, another awesome all-timer who got to it at some point, and the other one is our guest today.
克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris），另一位伟大的历史球员，他在某个时候达到了这一点，另一位是我们今天的嘉宾。
The writer of the show, Courtney Kang.
该剧的编剧是考特尼·康。
Courtney Kang.
考特尼·康.
Hi, Courtney.
嗨，考特尼。
Yeah.
是的。
Thank you so much for having me.
非常感谢你邀请我。
Oh my God, we're so happy you're here.
天哪，我们很高兴你在这里。
Thanks for giving us a decade of your life, by the way.
顺便说一句，谢谢你给了我们十年的生命。
Thanks for that.
谢谢你。
Yeah.
是的。
Thanks for that decade.
感谢那十年。
A full decade.
整整十年。
Yes.
是的。
What?
什么？
Like, did we carry?
比如，我们带了吗？
I don't think we got to 40, right?
我想我们还没到40岁吧？
You were both on our 30s and almost got, I think I'm a little older than you.
你们都30多岁了，我想我比你们大一点。
I think it'd be just shy of 40 when we did our 30s on how I met your mother, right?
我想当我们30多岁时我是如何认识你母亲的时候，我们的年龄还不到40岁，对吗？
That's pretty much it.
差不多就这样了。
I always tell people I started the show in my late 20s.
我总是告诉人们我在 20 多岁的时候开始了这个节目。
I was, I think I was like 28 or 29.
我当时大概是 28 或 29 岁。
I started the show like single.
我像单身一样开始了这个节目。
I had just started dating my now husband and I left the show a mother of two like staring down 40.
我刚刚开始和我现在的丈夫约会，当我离开节目时，我已经是两个孩子的母亲了，就像凝视着 40 岁的人一样。
So it was those like, And I feel like what was great about it is all of us, we're kind of in that sort of same age bracket and we were going through what the gang was going through and that was totally informing the stories, like Lilian Marshall getting married, starting to have children, career stuff, like we were going through it with the gang and I think it was like, and we were all going through it.
所以，我觉得这件事的伟大之处在于我们所有人，我们都在同一年龄段，我们正在经历这帮人正在经历的事情，这完全是故事的内容，比如莉莲·马歇尔结婚，开始生孩子，职业生涯，就像我们和这帮人一起经历它一样，我认为我们都在经历它。
You know, the cast was going through their things, the writers, the crew, everybody.
你知道，演员们、编剧、工作人员、每个人都在检查他们的事情。
It wasn't like the Hollywood, you know, 28 year olds playing high school students kind of like silliness.
这不像好莱坞，你知道，28 岁的人扮演高中生有点愚蠢。
Like we were, we were in the pocket of the era that we were, we were showing, you know?
就像我们一样，我们处于我们所处时代的口袋里，我们正在展示，你知道吗？
And the writing, the writing staff wasn't like these grizzled veterans who'd been doing it lots of years.
而写作，写作人员并不像这些已经干了很多年的头发花白的退伍军人。
And if this show doesn't work out, we'll go on to some other show like this was our shot, right?
如果这个节目不成功，我们会继续其他节目，就像我们的镜头一样，对吗？
This was our show.
这是我们的表演。
This was going to be our show.
这将是我们的表演。
We're the same age as the cast, Courtney, you were a little younger than me, but we were basically contemporaries and it felt like we were all sharing material and sharing stories and we all spoke the same language and I think that was like so key.
我们和演员们同龄，考特尼，你比我年轻一点，但我们基本上是同时代的人，感觉我们都在分享材料和故事，我们都说着同样的语言，我认为这很关键。
It's really interesting.
这真的很有趣。
Okay, so return of the shirt is of course a dating episode.
好吧，归还衬衫当然是约会的插曲。
It's not a relationship episode.
这不是一个关系情节。
It's like dating hell return of the shirt.
这就像约会地狱衬衫的归还一样。
You were like talk about do you remember because I don't where the idea originally came from of like that idea of going back to that person going back to that a person who's stuck in the back of your head and you go, wait a second.
你就像在谈论你还记得吗，因为我不知道这个想法最初是从哪里来的，就像回到那个人的想法，回到那个卡在你脑后的人，然后你走，等一下。
Why don't I try that again?
我为什么不再尝试一下呢？
Like, was that from, I forget if that was from your life or that was the room, just that specific thing of, I'm going to excavate back and find this person.
就像，那是来自，我忘记那是来自你的生活还是那个房间，只是那个特定的东西，我要挖掘回来并找到这个人。
Maybe that was the right person.
也许那是对的人。
Did that come from your life?
那是来自你的生活吗？
I forget.
我忘记了。
I think there were like two sort of fundamental truths that we got to that I think I might have brought to the room or that we sort of like build on or maybe somebody else did.
我认为我们得出了两种基本真理，我想我可能已经把它们带到了房间里，或者我们有点喜欢以此为基础，或者也许其他人已经这样做了。
I'm I'm not exactly sure, but the idea of it really being hard to break up with someone, rang, always rang very true to me.
我不太确定，但与某人分手确实很难的想法对我来说总是非常真实。
And I'm kind of like a path of least resistance person.
我有点像一个阻力最小的人。
And so I would just sort of like, ah, it's just easier to go along with this.
所以我想，啊，这样更容易接受。
And so I think like that was one of the germs of the idea of like, oh, like it's hard to break up with people.
所以我认为这就是“哦，很难与人分手”这一想法的萌芽之一。
And also the idea that it's so easy look back and reminisce and be like, hey, that person was great.
还有一个想法，就是很容易回顾和回忆，然后说，嘿，那个人很棒。
Like, maybe, maybe there's something there.
就像，也许，也许那里有什么东西。
Like that's, you know, like, well, why didn't that work out?
就像那样，你知道，就像，好吧，为什么没有成功？
And you sort of like, you know, you, you, you, you talk yourself into things, you know, and I think it's a little bit like wanting to rewrite history.
你有点喜欢，你知道，你，你，你，你说服自己去做一些事情，你知道，我认为这有点像想要重写历史。
It's a little bit the romantic idea of like, I've changed, you know, and so I think it was like, I think that's what I loved about the rewatch of this episode, I think it's grounded and there's these two very universal ideas that we all fall victim to.
这有点浪漫的想法，比如，我已经改变了，你知道，所以我认为，我认为这就是我喜欢重看这一集的原因，我认为它是有根据的，而且我们都成为这两个非常普遍的想法的受害者。
Yeah, it makes me think one thing about the agony of breakups and it's agonizing to be broken up with, but I have found it no less agonizing to break up with someone, especially if you care about them obviously, you've spent some significant time with them presumably, But also, like, I just don't like hurting people's feelings, right?
是的，这让我想到一件事，关于分手的痛苦，分手是痛苦的，但我发现与某人分手同样痛苦，特别是如果你显然很关心他们，你可能已经和他们一起度过了一些重要的时间，但同时，就像，我只是不喜欢伤害别人的感情，对吧？
Like, I avoid it at all costs, and there's something about the inability to have hard conversations, actually makes things much worse.
就像，我不惜一切代价避免它，而无法进行艰难的对话实际上会让事情变得更糟。
You end up making much more terrible decisions that hurt people.
你最终会做出更糟糕的决定，伤害别人。
And I also love that idea of the kind of, like, euphoric recall of a relationship.
我也喜欢那种对一段关系的欣快回忆的想法。
Like, you don't remember why you broke up with her.
比如，你不记得为什么和她分手。
You just, it's like, the highlight real of relationship comes back to you and you're like, they were delightful.
你只是，就像，关系中真正的亮点又回到了你身边，你就像，他们很令人愉快。
What was my problem?
我的问题是什么？
And then you think it must have been me.
然后你就会认为那一定是我。
It couldn't have been.
不可能的。
And I've tried to revisit some of those things.
我尝试重新审视其中的一些事情。
And you go in with the best of intentions.
你是带着最好的意图去的。
And it's astonishing how quickly you get back to the place where you're like, oh, yeah, this was never, this wasn't right.
令人惊讶的是，你很快就会回到原来的状态，哦，是的，这从来都不是，这是不对的。
It's not that they're a bad person.
这并不是说他们是坏人。
It's not that I'm the bad person.
这并不是说我是坏人。
In the episode, it is astonishingly fast.
在剧集中，速度快得惊人。
It's very tough.
这非常艰难。
It's very it's like I almost wish as every time you watch an episode now the my wife and I said we're rewatching it I go I wish we had five more minutes in this episode you know you think I was 25 and said a 22 because I'm like That felt very fast, but I guess that was also kind of the joke just like the second he gets her back He says I've got to get out of this which is funny.
这就像我几乎希望每次你看一集时我和我的妻子都会说我们要重看它我走了我希望我们在这一集里能再多看五分钟你知道你认为我25岁并说22因为我感觉那感觉很快，但我想这也是一个笑话就像他让她回来的那一刻他说我必须摆脱这很有趣。
It is funny.
这很有趣。
It's funny, but it's also brutal It's like yeah, what are you doing?
这很有趣，但也很残酷，就像是的，你在做什么？
Yeah, yeah, and you know why you don't know he doesn't ever show his work That's it.
是的，是的，你知道为什么你不知道他从不展示他的作品就是这样。
No, that was my that was it.
不，那是我的，就是这样。
He's just he never even explains why it's really is he just it's enough Oh, yeah, so Courtney also do you remember like where the the shirt that kind of talismanic object of the episode came from?
他只是他从来没有解释过为什么真的是他就足够了哦，是的，所以考特尼你还记得这一集的那种护身符的衬衫是从哪里来的吗？
I was I can't remember I couldn't remember that I feel like that was your pitch I feel like that like that idea of going back in your like the shirt is this key that unlocks a door into the past that leads to her right?
我不记得了，我不记得了，我觉得那是你的推销方式，我觉得就像穿着你的衬衫回到过去的想法，就像这件衬衫是一把钥匙，可以打开通往过去的大门，通向她，对吗？
Like I don't know.
就像我不知道一样。
How do we get there?
我们如何到达那里？
I can't remember how we got there.
我不记得我们是怎么到那里的。
I think I think it might have been a Carter thing that like the shirt that it like the shirt somehow connected it to the I don't I don't think I'm not.
我想我认为这可能是卡特的事情，喜欢这件衬衫，它喜欢这件衬衫，以某种方式将它与“我不，我不认为我不是”联系起来。
That feels like it could be a Carter thing.
感觉这可能是卡特的事。
Like Carter we come in with a new shirt and have a new personality.
就像卡特一样，我们穿着新衬衫并拥有新的个性。
Be like yeah.
就像是的。
Yeah.
是的。
I maybe it was a a room thing.
我也许这是一个房间的事情。
To be honest, I can't really remember.
说实话，我实在记不太清了。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
What's in.
里面有什么。
Oh, go please, go.
哦，请走吧，走吧。
No, I'm just going to say that's a good portrait of like what it's like to me in a writer's room because sometimes you know what you pitch.
不，我只是想说，这是一幅很好的写照，就像我在作家的房间里的感觉一样，因为有时你知道自己要推销什么。
And sometimes it's just like this hive mind kind of if we ask that entire room whose idea it was, it might be like, I don't know.
有时，就像蜂巢思维一样，如果我们问整个房间的想法是谁的，他们可能会说，我不知道。
Yeah.
是的。
Totally.
完全。
It's just an interesting writer's room observation.
这只是一次有趣的作家室观察。
We keep going.
我们继续前进。
I got you off.
我让你下车了。
No, it's also, it's also like a writer's room observation is like like things that I'm like, I think that was me.
不,也,也像在作家的房间里观察的那样,像我这样的东西,我想那就是我。
I have this like fear some writers listening to be able to be like, that was my idea.
我有这样的恐惧，有些作家听后会说，那是我的想法。
How dare she.
她怎么敢。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I see that every time.
我每次都看到这一点。
I'm like, I got three kids.
我想，我有三个孩子。
I don't know what I said.
我不知道我说了什么。
I don't know anything anymore.
我什么都不知道了。
In thinking about the inception of the idea, I remember one thing that the room got really excited about was your character previous to this episode had been pining, had been interested in Robin and had been going after her.
在思考这个想法的开始时，我记得房间里真正令人兴奋的一件事是你的角色在这一集之前一直在渴望，对罗宾感兴趣并一直在追求她。
And I remember we got really excited about the idea of kind of flipping the switch and putting you in the position where your character someone wanted you.
我记得我们对翻转开关并将你置于你的角色需要你的位置的想法感到非常兴奋。
And you were the one that had to break their heart.
而你就是那个让他们心碎的人。
And also I think it sort of helped to build up the Ted character of, he's this romantic guy who desperately wants to fall in love and wants the great girl.
而且我认为这在某种程度上有助于塑造泰德的性格，他是一个浪漫的人，非常想坠入爱河并想要一个伟大的女孩。
But also he's a character who women want and who women want to fall in love with.
但他也是女人想要、女人想要爱上的角色。
but it's not that easy.
但这并不那么容易。
It has to be someone great.
一定是一个伟大的人。
And so I think it kind of did good series groundwork.
所以我认为它为系列奠定了良好的基础。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's like Ted's not just a guy that pines after girls and he could get lots of girls.
但泰德似乎不仅仅是一个渴望女孩的人，而且他可以得到很多女孩。
He's had this history.
他有过这样的历史。
And so like put your character in this different light.
就像把你的角色放在不同的角度一样。
I think it was like, it was a new sort of like color for Ted.
我认为这对特德来说是一种新的颜色。
That's how we got there.
我们就是这样到达那里的。
And that's the kind of through line that gets you to an idea.
这就是让你产生想法的贯穿路线。
Because I think we did.
因为我想我们做到了。
We said, let's give that extra dimension to Ted.
我们说，让我们给特德额外的维度。
And I also remember, you're making me remember this, we said, let's scuff Ted up a little in this one.
我还记得，你让我记住了这一点，我们说，让我们在这件衣服上稍微磨损一下特德。
Let's make Ted in the right.
让我们让特德站在右边。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like he's, he can't just be this guy who gives great speeches and says all the right things and stuff just the stars on the line, but he's always going to be in the right Ted fucked up in this one.
就像他一样，他不能只是一个发表精彩演讲、说所有正确的事情和那些只是一线明星的东西的人，但他总是会在正确的地方泰德在这一场搞砸了。
Like he did.
就像他那样。
He did.
他做到了。
This was a bad.
这很糟糕。
Totally.
完全。
And like with most Ted, Ted screw ups, he has visible bruises and injuries to show for it.
和大多数泰德一样，泰德也搞砸了，他身上有明显的瘀伤和受伤。
I think this is the first time, like, that shows up black and blue, but not the last.
我认为这是第一次出现黑色和蓝色的情况，但不是最后一次。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，寄给你在纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back's the show.
现在，节目又回来了。
I mean, it's very check-off.
我的意思是，这是非常检查的。
The idea that this shirt is in Act One, and then in Act Three, the shirt has to get destroyed.
这件衬衫出现在第一幕中，然后在第三幕中，衬衫必须被毁掉。
It has to explode.
它必须爆炸。
Yes, the shirt is hung up over the fireplace.
是的，这件衬衫挂在壁炉上方。
It must be shot and I remember I love scenes that have no words that are very effective.
它必须被拍摄，我记得我喜欢那些没有非常有效的语言的场景。
I'm always has a screenwriter trying to write them.
我总是有一个编剧试图写它们。
I remember shooting the Ted looking through his closet and then seeing the shirt and pulling it out.
我记得拍摄特德查看他的衣柜，然后看到衬衫并将其拉出来。
I think I said, like, it almost feels like Samuel L.
我想我说过，就像，感觉就像塞缪尔·L·
Jackson's briefcase in politics.
杰克逊在政治中的公文包。
It's like coming off of it.
就像摆脱它一样。
And I remember we might have talked about this crack, but I remember I've such a strong strong memory, and it's so funny that this was nearly 20 years ago, Courtney, but when I walk into the bar wearing the shirt, and I think it's Ali who speaks first, Lily.
我记得我们可能讨论过这个裂缝，但我记得我有如此强大的记忆力，这很有趣，这已经是近 20 年前的事了，考特尼，但当我穿着衬衫走进酒吧时，我认为首先说话的是阿里，莉莉。
I forget what she says, like, woo, look at Mr. Shirt or something.
我忘记了她说的话，比如，求爱，看看衬衫先生什么的。
And I said, right, right.
我说，对，对。
And I remember in the run through, you just died at that.
我记得在整个过程中，你就死了。
Like you thought it was so funny.
就像你认为这很有趣一样。
And we couldn't remember if it just says, right, or if it was right, right.
我们不记得它只是说，对，还是对，对。
But somehow right, right, became a kind of mosebyism.
但不知何故，对，对，变成了一种莫斯比主义。
Like from that moment on, it was kind of like right, right, we did that hundreds of times I feel.
从那一刻起，感觉就像是对的，对的，我们这样做了数百次。
In the show.
在节目中。
Yeah.
是的。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Right.
正确的。
I love the remember Courtney laughing at that.
我喜欢记得考特尼对此大笑。
Courtney, you're so new.
考特尼，你真是新人。
You're kind of like, is this working?
你有点想，这有用吗？
And then you're like, oh, the writer of the episode likes this.
然后你就会想，哦，这一集的作者喜欢这个。
Like that felt good.
那样的感觉很好。
Yeah.
是的。
And she's laughing at your performance.
她正在嘲笑你的表现。
She's not arrogantly laughing at it.
她并没有傲慢地嘲笑它。
How funny is my jet?
我的飞机有多有趣？
Like that was just right.
就像那样刚刚好。
It's legitimately laughing at you.
它在合理地嘲笑你。
But I also love Marshall's line Hot Top, bro.
但我也喜欢 Marshall 的 Hot Top 系列，兄弟。
I've not always stayed with me.
我并不总是陪在我身边。
Brow.
眉头。
Hot Top, bro.
热顶，兄弟。
Just one more thing about the kind of scuffing up Ted as someone who's, who both desires and is desired and also gets his heart broken and breaks hearts.
还有一件事是关于泰德的那种磨损，他既渴望又被渴望，但也让他心碎又心碎。
Like I think if you're, if you're in the dating game long enough, you're gonna play all the roles.
就像我认为，如果你在约会游戏中玩得足够长，你就会扮演所有角色。
So it's not quite honest to just say like, Oh, this is a guy who always gets his heart broken or this is a guy who's always like leaving.
因此，仅仅说“哦，这是一个总是心碎的人，或者这是一个总是想离开的人”是不太诚实的。
Like, if you're in the game long enough, I don't like that, turn the game.
就像，如果你在游戏中玩的时间足够长，我不喜欢那样，那就转向游戏吧。
But if you're out there long enough, you do end up kind of being a hero in a villain depending on the night, you know?
但如果你在那里呆得足够长，你最终会成为恶棍中的英雄，这取决于夜晚，你知道吗？
Yeah, and I like that this episode, like Ted has real flaws.
是的，我喜欢这一集，就像特德有真正的缺陷一样。
Like, you know, like, it's not just, oh, he's just like shining night and shining armor, you know?
就像，你知道，就像，这不仅仅是，哦，他就像闪亮的夜晚和闪亮的盔甲，你知道吗？
Like, I remember there was a few moments on set with Carter that I think Ted not always behaving correctly is sometimes tough, tough for Carter.
就像，我记得和卡特一起在片场的一些时刻，我认为泰德不总是表现得正确有时对卡特来说很难，很难。
Did you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Because I remember Carter.
因为我记得卡特。
There was like a few moments of him being like, is this okay?
有那么一会儿他会想，这样可以吗？
Is this, is this bad?
这、这很糟糕吗？
Is this too much?
这太多了吗？
And I remember there was like a few moments.
我记得有那么一会儿。
I was like, you know, like, you know, because you're, it's in the beginning.
我当时想，你知道，就像，你知道，因为你，一切才刚刚开始。
You're just sort of like testing it out.
你只是想测试一下。
Yeah, it's a, it's a four.
是的，这是一个，这是一个四。
It's a four.
这是四号。
I mean, yeah.
我的意思是，是的。
So you're figuring out what this story can handle and what the audience is willing to accept.
所以你要弄清楚这个故事可以处理什么以及观众愿意接受什么。
Totally.
完全。
And we had an aired when we shot this episode, right?
我们拍摄这一集的时候已经播出了，对吧？
No.
不。
We would not have aired.
我们不会播出。
Yeah, we were good.
是的，我们很好。
So we really didn't know.
所以我们真的不知道。
Like we were inventing this world and hoping that it landed.
就像我们正在发明这个世界并希望它落地一样。
I have to say though, one of my all-time favorite, how I met your mother, Gags, is breaking up on the answer machine.
但我不得不说，我一直以来最喜欢的事情之一，就是我如何认识你的母亲，盖格斯，正在答录机上分手。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Well, people are gathered for a surprise party.
好吧，人们聚集在一起参加一个惊喜派对。
Is unbelievable.
令人难以置信。
I forgot.
我忘了。
I'm not kidding, Corny.
我不是在开玩笑，科尼。
Did you have any moments like this when you were watching it?
你在看的时候有没有这样的时刻呢？
And I'm almost sad to admit this, but I forgot that there was the widening out that we read.
我几乎很难过地承认这一点，但我忘记了我们所读到的内容正在扩大。
you saw the answering machine and then there's this other horrific reveal that makes it so much worse.
你看到了答录机，然后还有另一个可怕的揭露让事情变得更糟。
I sort of forgot about that second reveal.
我有点忘记了第二次揭露。
I don't know what happened in my brain, but I was like, I really, it really hit me.
我不知道我的脑子里发生了什么，但我想，我真的，这真的击中了我。
And I was, I was, it was hilarious.
我是，我是，这太搞笑了。
And it was also like, God, dead.
它也就像，上帝死了。
What were you doing, man?
你在做什么，伙计？
It was like, it's also, it's also, but you're, you're missing a joke.
就像，这也是，这也是，但是你，你错过了一个笑话。
It's three jokes, right?
这是三个笑话吧？
Because first, it's just the answering machine.
因为首先，它只是答录机。
Then it's pulled out, oh, you think everyone's listening.
然后就被拉出来了，哦，你以为每个人都在听。
And then no, she's not even there.
然后不，她根本不在那儿。
She has to come into the surprise reveal.
她必须参加令人惊讶的揭晓。
It's a triple reveal.
这是三重揭露。
Yeah.
是的。
Was there anything when you rewatched it that you didn't remember and it caught you?
当你重看的时候，有没有什么东西让你不记得了却又吸引了你？
I just, I forgot about the triple reveal, I guess is exact as a way to say it.
我只是，我忘记了三重揭示，我想这是准确的表达方式。
Yeah.
是的。
I totally forgot about the triple reveal, like it was the same thing for me.
我完全忘记了三重揭示，就像这对我来说是同一件事一样。
I was like, oh, that's funny.
我当时想，哦，这很有趣。
That's good.
那挺好的。
That was a good job.
那是一份好工作。
That's weird.
这很奇怪。
We were good.
我们很好。
I really did enjoy that.
我真的很喜欢这样。
The other thing that was sort of funny was, I sort of forgot the Robin Barney story in it.
另一件有趣的事情是，我有点忘记了其中罗宾·巴尼的故事。
Sometimes in my head, I don't match the right A-Stories with B-Stories.
有时在我的脑海里，我无法将正确的 A 故事与 B 故事相匹配。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
So when I saw it, I was like, all right, this.
所以当我看到它时，我想，好吧，这个。
And it's interesting because I remember in the breaking of it, in the early moments of the show, I think one of the characters we were really still trying to figure out was Robin.
这很有趣，因为我记得在节目的早期阶段，我认为我们仍在试图弄清楚的角色之一是罗宾。
Because it was like Ted loves Robin And she like, how do we make her after it?
因为这就像泰德爱罗宾而她也喜欢，我们如何让她之后呢？
How do we make her interesting?
我们怎样才能让她变得有趣呢？
How do we all these things?
我们如何做所有这些事情？
And I remember I was worried that the like, she's doing this shit on air.
我记得我很担心她会在广播中做这种事。
Like, will the audience disconnect from her?
比如，观众会与她断绝关系吗？
We thought she was like this career woman, but she doesn't give a shit.
我们以为她就像一个职业女性，但她不在乎。
And Kobe plays that all so well that she's sort of like, drawn to the dark side and there's like more to her.
科比在这一点上表现得非常好，以至于她有点像被黑暗面所吸引，但她还有更多的东西。
And I feel like it was sort of like, one of the first steps towards, you know, Robin became such a fun character to write and Kobe, what she did with it was always so amazing.
我觉得这有点像，罗宾成为一个写起来很有趣的角色和科比的第一步，她所做的总是那么令人惊奇。
And I feel like this was one of the steps zones along the way that you're like, oh, this girl's weird.
我觉得这是一路上的台阶区域之一，你会觉得，哦，这个女孩很奇怪。
This girl's got some like shit going on.
这个女孩有一些像狗屎一样的事情发生。
Like what's going on with her?
比如她怎么了？
You know, it's the first, I think it's the first one because we've now, we've done, this is our fourth episode we're doing on the podcast about.
你知道，这是第一集，我认为这是第一集，因为我们现在已经完成了，这是我们在播客上制作的第四集。
And this is the first one where she is purely in a comedy story.
这是她第一次纯粹出现在喜剧故事中。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
She has other things to do.
她还有其他事情要做。
She kind of, in episode three, sweet taste of liberty, she's kind of there in a way to serve as Lily's story.
在第三集中，她有点自由的甜蜜滋味，她在某种程度上充当了莉莉的故事。
Lily's thing about, she has her ring and she feels like she's noticed in the bar anymore.
莉莉的事情是，她带着戒指，感觉自己在酒吧里不再受到关注了。
And she sort of support it.
她有点支持。
And then the first two episodes, which we keep saying feels like an hour long episode, the first two episodes, the pilot and purple giraffe really are almost like an hour.
然后前两集，我们一直说感觉像是一个小时长的一集，前两集，飞行员和紫色长颈鹿真的几乎像一个小时。
She's the sought after object and she's the romantic comedy, like heroin, the female lead.
她是人们追捧的对象，她是浪漫喜剧的女主角，就像海洛因一样。
This is the first time she gets to be funny.
这是她第一次变得有趣。
And I think that's a really interesting point like it's a good way to frame it.
我认为这是一个非常有趣的观点，就像它是构建它的好方法一样。
This is this is the first time we really figured out she can just be in a comedy story.
这是我们第一次真正意识到她可以出现在喜剧故事中。
She said I think there was and that story.
她说我认为有那个故事。
It was also like you guys, it was the first time you were really mining her job for pure laughs.
也像你们一样，这是你们第一次真正挖掘她的工作纯粹的笑声。
Yeah.
是的。
And there's something so this is going to sound like such a weird comparison but Kobe's ability to like speak as a newscaster or like a reporter, like a metro reporter was it just came to her so easily.
这听起来像是一个奇怪的比较，但科比喜欢以新闻播音员或记者的身份说话的能力，就像地铁记者一样，这对她来说是如此容易。
It reminded me of this this is such a weird comparison, but Julianne Moore and Boogie Knight's, like her porn acting is so genius.
这让我想起这是一个如此奇怪的比较，但朱丽安·摩尔和布吉·奈特的色情表演是如此天才。
Like there's a kind of culture of there's newscaster speak, right?
就像有一种新闻播音员讲话的文化，对吧？
Have you ever seen that there's that woman on like TikTok or Instagram like who does like she narrates her family stuff through like the like a newscaster voice?
你有没有见过在 TikTok 或 Instagram 上有一个女人喜欢用新闻播音员的声音讲述她的家庭事务？
Oh nice.
哦，不错。
But Kobe just I always found, and especially when we introduced Sandy Rivers, Like there was so much good comedy on, what was it called Wake Up New York, or what was the early morning?
但我总是发现科比，尤其是当我们介绍桑迪·里弗斯时，就像有很多精彩的喜剧一样，它叫《唤醒纽约》，或者清晨是什么？
Oh my God, what was it called?
天哪，这叫什么名字？
Get up New York, something like that.
纽约起床，类似的事情。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
Yeah, it was really aggressive.
是的，确实很有侵略性。
It was like an aggressive title.
这就像一个咄咄逼人的标题。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
But I thought that was a fun, comedic well, to go back to over the years of Kobe at work, or Robin at work, and how, yeah, just like how no one was quite watched, How it was like this glamorous job, but it was also not glamorous, really.
但我认为这是一件有趣的、喜剧性的事情，可以回顾科比在工作中的岁月，或者罗宾在工作中的岁月，以及如何，是的，就像如何没有人完全关注，如何这就像这份迷人的工作，但它也并不迷人，真的。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's the moment she realizes no one watches this.
就在那一刻，她意识到没有人看到这一点。
Even her boss at the station doesn't watch the.
就连她在车站的老板也不看。
Yeah.
是的。
Shout out to Janet Kagan's husband.
向珍妮特·卡根的丈夫大声喊叫。
Janet Kagan, our script supervisor, her husband is great as that guy.
珍妮特·卡根（Janet Kagan）是我们的剧本主管，她的丈夫也很棒。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's the other thing we discovered in that episode in addition to just how funny Koby is.
除了科比有多有趣之外，这是我们在那一集中发现的另一件事。
And when you give her a straight up comedy story, her physical comedy's funny.
当你给她讲一个直接的喜剧故事时，她的肢体喜剧很有趣。
That's all that she does.
这就是她所做的一切。
That's all is great.
这一切都很棒。
Spanking her butt with like dead eyes was hilarious.
用死一般的眼睛打她的屁股真是太搞笑了。
Like completely dead inside spanking her, but because life has lost all meaning because no one watches what she does.
就像打她屁股时完全死了一样，但因为没有人看她所做的事情，生活失去了所有意义。
And this is her finding that out.
这是她发现的。
When she falls, that is a funny, I was watching with her back.
当她摔倒时，这很有趣，我在她的背上看着。
She hadn't watched that episode since an era, I think.
我想她已经很久没有看过那集了。
And she was, she lost her mind laughing my wife at that fall Kobe takes.
她是的，她在科比摔倒时嘲笑我的妻子，失去了理智。
It's also, it's also, it restores Barney as a literal devil.
这也是，这也是，它恢复了巴尼作为一个真正的魔鬼。
Like he's, we talked a lot about how like Barney's like the devil, he's the temper of this series.
就像他一样，我们谈论了很多关于巴尼如何像魔鬼一样，他是这个系列的脾气。
And he's literally just like cackling and handing out brides and like coming up with ever more devious schemes.
他真的就像咯咯笑并分发新娘一样，喜欢想出更狡猾的计划。
And he's, I mean, he's a bit of, he's the joker like he just wants to create chaos.
我的意思是，他有点像个爱开玩笑的人，就像他只想制造混乱一样。
He just wants to, yeah, he worships, he just wants to see it all burn down.
他只是想，是的，他崇拜，他只是想看到这一切都被烧毁。
You know what else really made me laugh?
你知道还有什么真正让我发笑吗？
It was such a small thing.
这是一件很小的事情。
But this is just a shout out to Ali Hannigan.
但这只是对阿里·汉尼根的喊叫。
Her laugh when she like makes herself laugh over the word booger is so honest, so natural.
当她喜欢的时候，她会笑，让自己因为“鼻屎”这个词而笑，是那么诚实，那么自然。
Like Ali, Ali really has that thing of like as if it's for the first time, like she's able to do that thing that is, is basically the basics of good acting, but she does it so consistently.
就像阿里一样，阿里确实有一种感觉，就好像这是第一次，就像她能够做那件事一样，这基本上是良好表演的基础，但她始终如一地这样做。
So naturally.
如此自然。
And she, I just felt like she really surprised herself with that.
而她，我只是觉得她对此感到非常惊讶。
I was delighted by it.
我很高兴。
Her laughing at booger was one of my favorite moments in the whole episode.
她嘲笑鼻屎是整集中我最喜欢的时刻之一。
it's right at the beginning and she just has this very, you're right.
一开始就是这样，她就是这样，你是对的。
It's a little throwaway, but it's so charming.
虽然有点随意，但是却很迷人。
It's funny because it's thrown away.
这很有趣，因为它被扔掉了。
Yeah.
是的。
The icky shuffle Courtney, was that you?
令人讨厌的洗牌考特尼，是你吗？
Was that you?
是你吗？
Was that, was that a shout out to your husband?
这是对你丈夫的喊叫吗？
I'm trying to think of where the hell we got the icky shuffle from.
我正在努力思考我们到底从哪里得到了令人讨厌的洗牌。
Yeah, I think like definitely I'm always trying to squeeze dancing into more dancing into things.
是的，我想我肯定一直在努力将舞蹈融入到更多的舞蹈中。
And so I think that did come from, I think the, yes, I want to say that was me, but if there's a higher out there that's out there like, like, fuck you, that was me, I apologize.
所以我认为这确实来自，我想，是的，我想说那是我，但如果外面有一个更高的人，就像，操你妈的，那就是我，我道歉。
This is a great glimpse into writer's minds.
这是对作家思想的一个很好的窥探。
You can't even take credit for one thing in this episode.
在这一集中，你甚至不能把任何一件事归功于自己。
You wrote this episode, you can say it.
这集是你写的，你可以说。
I did, I did.
我做到了，我做到了。
A lot of it to you.
给你很多。
Yeah, no, I think that might have been me, but yeah, it's funny.
是的，不，我想那可能是我，但是，是的，这很有趣。
I might rewatch to the other really fun thing I thought about the Rob and Barney story is exactly like you're saying how he's the Joker.
我可能会重看另一件非常有趣的事情，我认为罗布和巴尼的故事就像你说的他是如何成为小丑一样。
He, it sort of sets him up as the Devil and Lily, it sort of really solidifies her as like the angel on your shoulder, like trying to do good, wanting to, you know, in terms of like the dynamics of the show and like what everyone's bringing to the group, you know, I think it's a really nice, you know, and I feel like it's interesting, like it sort of sets up the, like, Barney, Robin have this dark side that they are in due.
他，这有点把他塑造成魔鬼和莉莉，这真的让她变得像你肩膀上的天使一样，就像努力做好事，想要，你知道，就节目的动态和每个人为团队带来的东西而言，你知道，我认为这真的很好，你知道，而且我觉得这很有趣，就像它有点让巴尼、罗宾有他们应有的黑暗面。
Like it sort of started the bond between them a little bit, you know, that ultimately obviously grew in series.
就像这有点开始了他们之间的联系，你知道，最终显然是系列化的。
But yeah, that storyline was, there was a surprise for me.
但是，是的，这个故事情节对我来说是一个惊喜。
I was like, oh, yeah, this is huge, you know what I mean?
我当时想，哦，是的，这太大了，你知道我的意思吗？
It's like the DNA is like you see where it was kind of planted in.
就好像 DNA 就好像你看到它被植入的地方一样。
It's not just martial Ted.
这不仅仅是武术泰德。
It's like martial Ted Lily, like and how invested Lily and Ted are, are Lily and martial are in making sure they have that like back porch fantasy together with the, the four, they want to get, they want to complete the quartet for Ted.
就像武术特德·莉莉一样，莉莉和泰德是如何投入的，莉莉和武术是为了确保他们与他们想要的四个人一起拥有像后门廊的幻想，他们想要为特德完成四重奏。
And she also wants him to do it, you know, her hitting him like 27 times in the episode.
她也希望他这么做，你知道，她在这一集中打了他 27 次。
Like she wants him to do it well.
就像她希望他把这件事做好一样。
She wants him to be a mench.
她希望他成为一个男人。
She wants him to like not, she wants him to be one of the good guys.
她希望他不喜欢，她希望他成为好人之一。
I could just shout out as we're thinking about this.
当我们思考这个问题时，我可以大声喊出来。
I want to call to Hannah Wells, who asks exactly this question.
我想打电话给汉娜·威尔斯，她问的正是这个问题。
And it goes to also Courtney, as you as the writer, I think I I think people are probably curious about this notion of you being the writer of an episode.
这也适用于考特尼，作为编剧，我想人们可能对你作为一集的编剧这一概念感到好奇。
This is the first time that we're talking about something like this where a story is broken in the room and then you go and write it but how does that connect to the other 10 writers that there are?
这是我们第一次谈论这样的事情，一个故事在房间里被打破，然后你去写它，但这与其他 10 位作家有什么联系呢？
And she asks, was Lily always supposed to be Ted's greatest teacher in love or does that spark happen in this episode?
她问，莉莉一直被认为是泰德最伟大的爱情老师，还是这一集里发生了这种火花？
So can you talk about what your job is as the writer as compared to what the room is doing and what you're inventing versus what they're inventing.
那么你能谈谈作为作家你的工作是什么，与房间正在做的事情相比，以及你正在发明什么与他们正在发明什么。
And this question about who came up with this idea of what that relationship would be between Lily and Ted?
这个问题是谁提出了莉莉和特德之间的关系的想法？
Yeah, I mean, Craig, jump in too.
是的，我的意思是，克雷格，也加入进来。
It's a writer of an episode can mean so many different things on different shows.
一个剧集的编剧在不同的节目中可能意味着很多不同的事情。
And in different instances, it means something different.
而且在不同的情况下，它的含义也不同。
I feel like in this specific instance, the way I think what was so great about the way how I met your mother broke your stories, broke stories in the way that Carter and Craig led the room is it always started from like, here's a real thing that happens to me or here's something I noticed or here's something about relationships and people would jump in and go, oh my God, that happened to me.
我觉得在这个特定的例子中，我认为我遇见你母亲的方式如此伟大，以卡特和克雷格领导房间的方式讲述故事，它总是从这样开始，这是发生在我身上的真实的事情，或者这是我注意到的事情，或者这是关于人际关系的事情，人们会跳进来，说，天哪，这发生在我身上。
And so if I had to guess, my guess was we started talking about like, it's hard to break up with people and everybody shared their stories of things they done and it's like, oh my God, what if Ted has to do that?
所以如果我不得不猜测，我的猜测是我们开始谈论这样的事情，与人分手很难，每个人都分享他们所做的事情的故事，就像，天哪，如果特德必须这样做怎么办？
Oh my God, then what if it's his birthday, you know, and what if it's these things And it's sort of like, you know, it kind of grows.
哦天哪，那如果今天是他的生日怎么办，你知道，如果是这些东西怎么办？它有点像，你知道，它有点增长。
And that's when a room is fantastic, there's nothing more fun than like pitching on it all together.
当一个房间非常棒时，没有什么比把所有东西放在一起更有趣的了。
And then essentially, you know, we sort of go, okay, we have this idea.
然后基本上，你知道，我们有点走，好吧，我们有这个想法。
And then you put it up on a dry erase board and you beat out, you know, the beats of the story of what it can be.
然后你把它放在一块干擦板上，然后你就敲出了故事的节奏。
And then the writer, I would go off and like put it in an outline and like a word document.
然后作者，我会把它写成一个大纲，就像一个文字文档一样。
It's like, okay, this scene, this scene.
就像，好吧，这个场景，这个场景。
Oh, here's a funny joke here, here's a funny joke there.
哦，这里有一个有趣的笑话，那里有一个有趣的笑话。
And then they would come back in the room and everybody would pitch on it, have thoughts and Carter and Craig would really sort of lead, you know, where the ship is going.
然后他们会回到房间，每个人都会讨论它，有想法，卡特和克雷格会真正引导，你知道，船要去哪里。
And I think, you know, you guys were great showrunners in that I think they had a really clear North Star of the story they wanted to tell.
我认为，你们知道，你们都是出色的制片人，因为我认为他们对自己想要讲述的故事有一个非常清晰的北极星。
And then as a writer, it's your job to pitch on how we can get there.
然后，作为一名作家，你的工作就是推动我们如何实现这一目标。
Like this is, I'll row this way.
就这样，我就这样划船。
You row that way and then we'll, you know what I mean?
你这样划船，然后我们就可以了，你明白我的意思吗？
We all knew where we were going, like there was a certain tone to the show, like it was really funny, but it was very grounded and had heart.
我们都知道我们要去哪里，就像这个节目有一定的基调，就像它真的很有趣，但它非常脚踏实地，充满爱心。
And so then you go off and you write the episode and then you bring it back again into the room and people pitch on it.
然后你就开始写这一集，然后再把它带回房间，人们就开始讨论它。
And it's interesting because a lot of times stories will change from, you know, things will change from a writer's draft, but Rob Greenberg who, you know, I used to call him Puppup because he was so much older and I'd since discovered I'm like now like 10 years older than he ever he was so young.
这很有趣，因为很多时候故事会随着作家的草稿而改变，但罗布·格林伯格，你知道，我以前叫他“小狗”，因为他老了很多，后来我发现我现在比他年长了10岁，他是如此年轻。
He was an old guy at like 39 or whatever the fuck yeah.
他是个39岁左右的老家伙了，是的。
I'm sorry but I remember he once said if you write a script and every line every joke changes but the story is the same and you made the story work like that's a good draft you know because sometimes his writer is there's like a joke you love or a moment that sometimes changes for one reason or another it ultimately doesn't serve the character where we want to go.
我很抱歉，但我记得他曾经说过，如果你写一个剧本，每行每一个笑话都会改变，但故事是一样的，你把故事写得像一个很好的草稿，你知道，因为有时他的作家会在那里写一个你喜欢的笑话，或者有时因为这样或那样的原因而改变的时刻，它最终不会服务于我们想要去的角色。
And so yeah, so I went off and wrote this script and fun fact, this is the first TV script I wrote that actually made it to the air.
所以，是的，所以我开始写这个剧本，有趣的是，这是我写的第一个真正播出的电视剧本。
Oh my gosh.
天哪。
Yes, I had written other ones that the show has all got canceled before.
是的，我写过其他的节目之前都被取消了。
I was always like episode like three or four and then it was like, you know, got like two and out or something.
我总是喜欢三四集，然后就像，你知道，有两集然后就出局了或者什么的。
And so So this was a very big, this was a very big deal for me.
所以这对我来说是一件非常大的事情。
You did not advertise that fact when we hired you, that you read episodes of Shadows and they get canceled before the air.
当我们雇用你时，你没有宣传这一事实：你读过《影子》的剧集，但它们在播出前就被取消了。
We might have thought twice, but you know, you should have told us Courtney one of the things.
我们可能会三思而后行，但你知道，你应该告诉我们考特尼其中一件事。
One of the things we're exploring on this show is why this show inspires so much fervor and why is it so beloved and why do people watch it over and over and why do people watch it when they're going through a really hard time in their lives.
我们在这个节目中探索的事情之一是为什么这个节目激发了如此多的热情，为什么它如此受人喜爱，为什么人们一遍又一遍地观看它，为什么人们在经历生活中真正困难的时候还要观看它。
there's all these kind of like mysteries at the heart of what has made this show so durable.
正是这些类似的谜团让这部剧经久不衰。
And I think you're hitting on something which is there would be no story that was pitched or accepted to kind of be turned into a draft unless it was grounded in something real.
我认为你正在抓住一个问题，那就是除非故事是基于真实的东西，否则不会有任何故事被提出或接受而变成草稿。
So I think when even if the story could spin off into Bonkers land and it was lit really brightly on a sound stage in Hollywood and in LA and there was laughter coming through, that was piped in, it still had this feeling that like I know these people or this happened to me.
所以我认为，即使这个故事可以延伸到疯狂之地，在好莱坞和洛杉矶的摄影棚里灯光非常明亮，并且传出笑声，但它仍然有一种感觉，就像我认识这些人或这件事发生在我身上。
And I think that's what that's what that's what a lot of what people resonate with.
我认为这就是很多人产生共鸣的原因。
And I'll give Courtney a lot.
我会给考特尼很多。
Courtney, one thing I love about you, I love many things about you, but you were always so good at bringing in real life stuff and bringing in like the basic raw material that could then lead to the story having that feeling.
考特尼，我爱你的一件事，我爱你的很多方面，但你总是很擅长引入现实生活中的东西，引入基本的原材料，从而使故事具有那种感觉。
Josh just described.
乔什刚刚描述过。
Just starting with something real, starting with like it's hard to break up with people.
从一些真实的事情开始，从像很难与人分手一样开始。
It's hard to be broken up with.
很难被分手。
It's hard to to break up with people, starting with that idea of like how finding a thing can kind of unlock a portal to the past, right?
与人分手很难，从这样的想法开始，比如找到一件东西可以打开通往过去的大门，对吗？
He finds a shirt and somehow the Rube Goldberg machine gets created from that point.
他找到了一件衬衫，不知何故，鲁布·戈德堡机器从那时就被创造出来了。
And from that point, you say the shirt leads back to this girl, leads back to this whole sorted tale of how he broke up with her, leads to him getting back into her life and breaking up with her again, also on her birthday in the worst way possible and culminating in tagging and she had kicked out of them.
从那时起，你说这件衬衫又回到了这个女孩，回到了他如何与她分手的整个故事，导致他回到她的生活并再次与她分手，也是在她生日那天以最糟糕的方式，最终以标签的方式被她踢出了他们。
That shot, it's in slow motion of the PO Ted's POV, as easy as he could be.
那个镜头是 PO Ted 的 POV 的慢动作，尽可能简单。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I forgot that.
我忘记了。
And she was so hilarious.
她真是太搞笑了。
Yeah.
是的。
Shout out to any dude at.
向任何家伙大喊大叫。
Any dude at.
任何家伙在。
Yes.
是的。
She did so good.
她做得很好。
She and I ended up becoming really good friends.
我和她最终成为了非常好的朋友。
Like, a lot of people don't, like, these people, you're just on stage 22 and all these incredible actors and dynamic person, they come to the set and you, some of them you really take with you.
就像，很多人不喜欢，这些人，你只是在第 22 舞台上，所有这些令人难以置信的演员和充满活力的人，他们来到片场，而你，其中一些你真的随身携带。
just hi Annie if you're listening.
如果你在听的话，嗨安妮。
She was so good on that episode.
那一集她演得非常好。
Perfect.
完美的。
And so I don't know she was so, she looked like strong and confident and completely woundable all at the same time.
所以我不知道她是不是这样，她看起来坚强、自信，但同时又很容易受伤。
Yeah, her fragility and her like, I can't believe I let myself, this happened to me again.
是的，她的脆弱和她的喜欢，我不敢相信我让自己，这又发生在我身上。
I love the flashbacks to like when he's going through like, oh whatever happened to so and so whatever happened so and so I always loved when Ted could be like a silent film star like when he could just like drop a meatball and like have a you know one of my luck.
我喜欢闪回，喜欢当他经历的时候，哦，无论某某发生了什么，无论某某发生了什么，我总是喜欢泰德像一个无声电影明星，就像他可以扔下一个肉丸，就像有一个你知道我的运气一样。
And that final scene between the two of us at that restaurant I think is just so funny.
我觉得我们两个在那家餐厅的最后一幕真是太有趣了。
I did have this thought when I saw the shirt, I was like why didn't I button one more button?
当我看到这件衬衫时，我确实有这样的想法，我想为什么我不再扣一颗纽扣呢？
Like it looked like two and I remember I think the costume designer and I had a conversation Okay, we're going to not button that one, but when you go out to dinner, you're going to button the one, uh, because it's fancy, you know, now it's fancy.
就像它看起来像两颗，我记得我想服装设计师和我谈过一次，好吧，我们不会扣那个扣子，但是当你出去吃饭时，你会扣那个扣子，呃，因为它很花哨，你知道，现在它很花哨。
Right.
正确的。
So how many days is Ted Berryman churning around?
那么特德·贝里曼（Ted Berryman）要转行多少天？
Yeah, it's seriously.
是的，这很严重。
He really, he really works it for that whole week.
他真的，他真的花了整整一个星期的时间。
Or however long they're together.
或者无论他们在一起多久。
I mean, that's kind of the part of the funny, like, non-reality of it is he never takes off the shirt.
我的意思是，这就是有趣的部分，就像，非现实的是他从不脱掉衬衫。
It's ridiculous.
这太荒谬了。
But I loved, uh, I loved your awesome.
但我喜欢，呃，我喜欢你的精彩。
Like, I loved that runner.
就像，我喜欢那个跑步者。
So funny.
太有趣了。
It's really funny.
真的很有趣。
You play that print.
你播放那个印刷品。
I think ineffable is one of the great how I met your mother jokes.
我认为不可言喻是我如何认识你母亲的最好笑话之一。
I'm not I'm not affable.
我不是我不友善。
That's a Craig Thomas Joe Craig Thomas.
那是克雷格·托马斯乔·克雷格·托马斯。
I remember when he pitched that it with the room like lost it.
我记得当他把它和房间一起推销时就像失去了它一样。
That was so good.
那太好了。
So good.
超好的。
I'm not going to be modest.
我不会谦虚。
I'm going to say yes.
我会说是的。
That was mine.
那是我的。
That was a great joke.
这是一个天大的笑话。
Courtney is like a good person.
考特尼就像一个好人。
She's like I'm not sure I'm like that's mine.
她就像我不确定我是不是我的一样。
And this old man.
还有这个老人。
He We must did me, fell in love with you, knew you were a city.
他我们一定做了我，爱上了你，知道你是一座城市。
And now, commercials!
现在，广告！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客，或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials back to show.
广告结束返回放映。
I love the lather that Ted gets worked into trying to be a good guy and he can't get out of this.
我喜欢泰德为了成为一个好人而付出的努力，但他却无法摆脱这个困境。
And it's her birthday and he doesn't want to do it.
今天是她的生日，他不想这样做。
And he knows he has to do it.
他知道他必须这样做。
And just ending with, I'm just like super busy right now.
最后，我现在超级忙。
Love that, I like that.
喜欢那个，我喜欢那个。
Really made me laugh.
真的让我笑了。
And by the time he gets kicked by her, you're kind of like just put him out of his misery, like just end this thing.
当他被她踢的时候，你就像让他摆脱痛苦一样，就像结束这件事一样。
Like it's really brutal.
好像真的很残酷。
By the way, I think you couldn't, you couldn't on CVS say, go F yourself or say F to mean the F word, but that's why in F of all was really delightful.
顺便说一句，我认为你不能，你不能在 CVS 上说，你自己去 F 或说 F 来表示 F 词，但这就是为什么在 F 中真的很令人愉快。
I was really worried it was gonna get knocked out because it kind of is saying F of all, but because we headed within an actual word we got it, and that was, I remember taking great joy.
我真的很担心它会被淘汰，因为它有点像是在说“F”，但因为我们在一个实际的单词中前进，所以我们得到了它，那就是，我记得非常高兴。
It's the fact that we sort of like flew under the sensor's radar.
事实上，我们有点像在传感器的雷达下飞行。
Is it really this word?
真的是这个词吗？
It's like the Hollywood code in the four years.
这就像四年来的好莱坞密码。
like you had to, you had to smuggle stuff in.
就像你必须做的那样，你必须偷运东西进来。
Yeah.
是的。
Really?
真的吗？
I do.
我愿意。
Yeah.
是的。
Go ahead.
前进。
No, I was going to say, I do remember that quick.
不，我想说，我确实记得那么快。
Because like, you would get the memo of the, like, standards and practices.
因为，您会收到有关标准和实践的备忘录。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
We were so nervous.
我们很紧张。
And I remember, I was like running.
我记得，我喜欢跑步。
It was like, Christmas morning.
就像圣诞节的早晨。
Did you dig in?
你挖进去了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's a word.
这是一个词。
It's really over.
真的结束了。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's set up early in the episode in an organic way.
它是在剧集的早期以有机的方式设置的。
And it comes back around.
它又回来了。
Yeah.
是的。
So we were clever on that one.
所以我们在这一点上很聪明。
I also remember getting the spaghetti thrown at me.
我还记得有人向我扔意大利面条。
And, you know, the crew delighted in that.
而且，你知道，工作人员对此很高兴。
I remember that, but also having props and costume come on and trying to drape, like, they're trying to recreate the first taste and they have to like recreate the pasta splatter on me.
我记得这一点，但也有道具和服装，并试图披上，就像，他们试图重新创造第一味道，他们必须喜欢重新创造意大利面溅在我身上。
In those moments, you're like, what's my job?
在那些时刻，你会想，我的工作是什么？
How am I getting paid?
我如何获得报酬？
People are placing pasta on my body and that's my job today.
人们把意大利面放在我身上，这就是我今天的工作。
Yeah.
是的。
That's a weird job.
这是一项奇怪的工作。
It's a living.
这是一种生活。
Courtney, and like, even the Robin story.
考特尼，甚至罗宾的故事。
I feel like the thing you just said about you were working on shows, you'd write the episodes.
我觉得你刚才说的你正在制作节目，你会写剧集。
I think you even got episodes produced and shot.
我想你甚至还制作和拍摄了剧集。
I'm remembering this whole story now.
我现在还记得整个故事。
And then the show would get canceled before it would air, right?
然后节目在播出之前就被取消了，对吗？
I feel like even in the Robin story, you were channeling something.
我觉得即使在罗宾的故事中，你也在传达一些东西。
That idea of like, I'm doing something no one sees.
那种想法就像是，我正在做一些没有人看到的事情。
Like you experienced that in your actual writing life.
就像您在实际写作生活中经历过的那样。
And I always feel like there was something you always found a way to get like some of your yourself and your life and some like truths in there.
我总觉得有些东西你总能找到一种方式来获得像你自己和你的生活以及其中的一些真理。
And then again, you build this big Rube Goldberg machine with the writer's room after that.
然后，你再用作家的房间建造这个大型鲁布·戈德堡机器。
And you say, what's the worst way Ted could break up with this girl?
你说，泰德与这个女孩分手最糟糕的方式是什么？
What's the steepest climb to get back in the girl's life?
要回到女孩的生活中，最陡峭的攀爬是多少？
That's how you get to the triple reveal joke about it's an answering machine.
这就是你如何得到关于它是一台答录机的三重揭示笑话。
It's a surprise party.
这是一场惊喜派对。
Ted will always be the guy that broke up with her in an answering machine during her surprise party.
泰德永远是在她的惊喜派对上通过答录机与她分手的人。
And we constructed that elaborate thing to create this steep hell for Ted to climb.
我们建造了那个复杂的东西来创造这个陡峭的地狱供泰德攀爬。
But it doesn't start there.
但事情并非从这里开始。
It starts from like, let's do an episode about just how hard it is to break up with someone.
首先，让我们制作一集来讲述与某人分手是多么困难。
And then what's the worst way we can imagine that?
那么我们能想象到的最糟糕的方式是什么？
And he has to clear that hurdle and then break up with her again.
他必须清除这个障碍，然后再次与她分手。
So it's like where I feel like, now I made your mother was marrying two worlds.
所以这就像我的感觉，现在我让你的母亲嫁给了两个世界。
It was marrying this like truthful, like more like indie film world with a sitcom.
它将真实、更像独立电影世界与情景喜剧结合在一起。
Cause you have this incredibly truthful thing, but then you spin it into this like comedic kind of Sunday, right?
因为你有这个令人难以置信的真实的东西，但然后你把它变成了喜剧式的周日，对吧？
Like where you're just like, it's insane.
就像你现在的情况一样，这太疯狂了。
You couldn't, you couldn't quite get away with this in a movie.
你不能，你不能在电影中完全逃脱惩罚。
I mean, maybe like a broad comedy or something, but it really, it really keeps it grounded in like sitcom land, but also grounded in this other truthful space that I think how my mother was like really pioneering around.
我的意思是，也许就像一部广泛的喜剧或其他东西，但它真的，它确实让它扎根于情景喜剧领域，但也扎根于另一个真实的空间，我认为我的母亲是如何真正开拓的。
Yes.
是的。
And I think the, I think quite what you're remembering.
我想，我想和你所记得的一样。
So I had been on these shows that all got canceled.
所以我参加过这些节目，但都被取消了。
And I had recently gone to my 10 year high school reunion, and people were like, what do you do?
我最近参加了我的 10 周年高中同学聚会，人们问我，你是做什么的？
And I was like, I'm a TV writer.
我当时想，我是一名电视作家。
And they were like, well, like shows do you write on?
他们就像，嗯，就像你写的节目一样？
And I go, oh, they haven't made it to me.
我走了，哦，他们还没有成功。
And they don't exist theoretical shows.
而且它们不存在理论表演。
You'll never see it.
你永远不会看到它。
Yeah, they were like, what do you mean?
是的，他们就像，你是什么意思？
I'm like, well, it happens all the time.
我想，好吧，这种事经常发生。
Like networks, like this was, you know, post must see TV.
就像网络一样，就像这样，你知道，帖子必须看电视。
Like there are money's going everywhere.
就像到处都有钱一样。
And I was like, well, you can make shows and then you make episodes, but then they don't air.
我当时想，好吧，你可以制作节目，然后制作剧集，但随后它们就不会播出了。
And so like literally people in my high school were hearing them were like, so you make TV shows, but they're not on TV.
就像我高中的人听到的那样，所以你制作电视节目，但它们不在电视上。
It was literally like Romeo and Michelle, like I invented Post-its.
它真的就像罗密欧和米歇尔，就像我发明了便利贴一样。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I was like, no, I'm a TV writer, I swear.
我当时想，不，我发誓，我是一名电视作家。
And so I remember when this episode finally aired, I had gotten over the hump and the curse, the curse was reversed.
所以我记得当这一集最终播出时，我已经克服了困难和诅咒，诅咒被逆转了。
And so.
所以。
But you know what else is weird?
但你知道还有什么奇怪的吗？
The thing you're describing, that kind of liminal state where you're not quite on the air, but you're actually making a living being a TV writer.
你所描述的事情，就是那种你不太在广播中的临界状态，但你实际上是以电视编剧的身份谋生的。
Totally.
完全。
Like in Hollywood, you're weirdly successful.
就像在好莱坞一样，你取得了惊人的成功。
People in the industry would know exactly what you'd been doing.
业内人士会确切地知道你一直在做什么。
They would even write about the pilots.
他们甚至会写关于飞行员的文章。
you wrote on, but like the back home people, the high school friends knowing that your successful Hollywood is a whole different game than Hollywood knowing you're successful.
你写了，但就像家乡的人一样，高中的朋友知道你在好莱坞的成功与好莱坞知道你的成功是完全不同的游戏。
Totally, totally.
完全，完全。
And so yeah, I think that like existential idea of like, I'm working hot, like I'm on air, I'm a newscaster, but like nobody sees me, nobody fucking gives a shit.
所以，是的，我认为就像存在主义的想法一样，我工作很热，就像我在广播中一样，我是一名新闻播音员，但就像没有人看到我一样，没有人他妈的在乎。
Like I think you were telling that.
就像我认为你是这么说的。
I really do.
我真的这么做。
I think that's the like nugget of reality.
我认为这就是现实的真相。
I'm gonna do one.
我要做一个。
That's the kernel of truth.
这就是真理的核心。
Kernel of truth.
真理的核心。
stumble upon it, that makes that grounds that story.
偶然发现它，这就是这个故事的基础。
And then the story is so much fun off of that.
然后这个故事就非常有趣了。
And it seems like crazy nonsense.
这似乎是疯狂的胡言乱语。
But there is actually something a little bit true even in that very funny B story.
但即使在那个非常有趣的 B 故事中，实际上也有一些真实的东西。
And I think those stories, when you come into the room and you tell the story about the existential feeling of going in your history and not being able to prove you, actually, people think you're lying.
我认为这些故事，当你走进房间，讲述关于你的历史的存在感的故事，但实际上无法证明你，人们认为你在撒谎。
She's pretending she's a TV writer.
她假装自己是电视作家。
That feeling goes into that episode, I think.
我想，那种感觉也融入到了那一集里。
And that's what I loved about our room.
这就是我喜欢我们房间的原因。
Our room is very confessional, right?
我们的房间很忏悔，对吧？
people, you just felt safe telling stories like that.
各位，讲这样的故事你会感到很安全。
And then it would lead if somehow it would whether intentionally or not, it would sort of like biosmosis go into a story like that.
然后它会以某种方式引导，无论是有意还是无意，这有点像生物渗透进入这样的故事。
I don't even remember if we literally connected that episode of your life to this episode of TV.
我什至不记得我们是否真的将你生活中的那一集与电视中的这一集联系起来。
But I think we did.
但我想我们做到了。
I think we probably talked all about that idea of like being at the beginning of your career and just wanting so badly to feel like you're important and impressive and the moment you realize you're not.
我想我们可能都讨论过这样的想法：就像在你职业生涯的开始时，你非常想要感觉自己很重要、令人印象深刻，但当你意识到自己并不重要时。
And that Robin getting to go just completely dead eyed and fall apart inside because she realizes no one watches her at all.
罗宾完全睁大了眼睛，内心崩溃了，因为她意识到根本没有人看她。
And then at the end she has like this minor victory of like, well, people did watch.
最后，她取得了这样的小胜利，人们确实观看了。
This thing where I saw in horses seems to be catching up.
我在马身上看到的这个东西似乎正在迎头赶上。
There's also something nice I imagine.
我想象中也有一些美好的东西。
I'm not I wasn't in a writer in the room.
我不是我不是在一个作家的房间里。
But there must be something kind of weird and nice about having these autobiographical like moments or or sketches like make it onto the air.
但是，让这些自传式的瞬间或草图之类的内容播出肯定有一些奇怪和美好的东西。
And it's not, it's not you, but there's something of like your beating heart and your biography that like went out there and delighted people.
不是，不是你，而是有一些东西，比如你跳动的心和你的传记，让人们感到高兴。
In your first ever produced episode, which is also kind of sweet.
在你制作的第一集里，这也很甜蜜。
I totally thought that was your first.
我完全以为那是你的第一次。
So what did it feel?
那么感觉如何呢？
I think you've shot that episode at the end of that week.
我想你在那周末就已经拍摄了那一集。
Did it feel like, shit, I'm really a TV writer now.
是不是感觉，妈的，我现在真的是一名电视编剧了。
I really, or did it take it?
我真的，还是真的接受了？
Did you need it to air?
你需要它来播出吗？
The show had to not get cancelled before it aired.
该节目在播出前不得被取消。
I needed it to air like each I was on four shows before this one I didn't get a script one I got a script and I didn't get to shoot it the next one I got to write a script and I got to shoot it and literally when we came to set to shoot it it was Danny Zucker was like guys I have an announcement the show's canceled but we're going to shoot this episode tonight So that's you can imagine the energy must have been through the roof.
我需要它像每一部一样播出，在这之前我没有拿到剧本，第一部我有剧本，我没有拍摄下一部，我必须写剧本，我必须拍摄它，从字面上看，当我们开始拍摄时，丹尼·扎克就像伙计们一样，我宣布该剧被取消，但我们今晚要拍摄这一集，所以你可以想象，能量一定已经达到了顶峰。
When this one finally it was crazy like this was like a wild time for me because this was my first episode that I wrote it made it to TV and I think we aired on a Monday and the Sunday before this aired my no the Saturday before this aired my husband proposed and so like I got engaged my episode aired like I was like wow it's it's all happening like this is like you know and so it was a really and I know you it was really special you had been engaged for other times but never made it to the altar and this was the one this is the one oh and this is fun I was I was remembering this the sock monkeys my husband I remember when we first started dating my husband loved sock Monkeys and he had like he had this like tiny it was like this big like little sock monkey like the sock monkey thing.
当这一集最终变得疯狂时，这对我来说就像是一段疯狂的时光，因为这是我写的第一集在电视上播出，我想我们在星期一播出，而在此之前的星期日播出了我的不，在播出之前的星期六我丈夫求婚了，所以就像我订婚了，我的这一集播出了，我就像哇，这一切都发生了，就像你知道的那样，所以这真的是，我知道你，这真的很特别，你已经订婚过其他次了，但从未登上圣坛，就是这个，就是这个哦，这很有趣，我记得我丈夫的袜子猴子，我记得当我们第一次开始约会时，我丈夫喜欢袜子猴子，他喜欢他有这个像小袜子猴子一样大的东西，就像袜子猴子一样。
I don't think I ever knew that.
我想我从来不知道这一点。
Shout out to Zach.
向扎克大喊。
I love the sock monkeys.
我喜欢袜子猴子。
Yeah.
是的。
Inspiration like I remember was like on his shelf and I was like what's this?
我记得灵感就在他的架子上，我就想这是什么？
He's like I just think sock monkeys are like cute.
他就像我只是觉得袜子猴很可爱。
Oh, which reminds me.
哦，这让我想起了。
Yeah.
是的。
I have a I have a special guest who can join us.
我有一位特殊的客人可以加入我们。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
Is that it?
是这样吗？
It's not from the episode.
这不是剧集里的
That's enough.
这就够了。
This is the the sock monkey.
这是袜子猴。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
That's so great.
那太好了。
That was an excellent reveal for the mystery.
这是对这个谜团的极好的揭示。
Why go to YouTube and watch this this moment.
为什么现在要去 YouTube 观看这个呢？
A gigantic as big as Courtney sock monkey is sitting next to Courtney now.
一只和考特尼袜子猴一样大的巨大猴子现在坐在考特尼旁边。
Was that your pregnancy pillow?
那是你的怀孕枕头吗？
It should have been.
本来应该如此。
But yeah, I remember.
但是，是的，我记得。
Well, that was also fine.
嗯，那也很好。
I remember.
我记得。
I think it was like fill Lord.
我认为这就像填补主。
And I think it was like, so it was Dale or Chris or somebody was like, dude, you know, when you're a writer, if If you write shit and do an episode, they have to get it.
我想，就像是戴尔或克里斯，或者有人说，伙计，你知道，当你是一名作家时，如果你写了一些屎并做了一集，他们就必须得到它。
And then you can have it.
然后你就可以拥有它了。
And then you just take it home.
然后你就把它带回家。
So that's what that was.
就是这样。
That was, they got that, they got that for the episode.
也就是说，他们得到了这一点，他们得到了这一集的内容。
You didn't bring that to the episode.
你没有把它带到这一集。
They got that sock one.
他们得到了那只袜子。
No, they got it.
不，他们明白了。
So they said, I'm bringing this home to Zach.
所以他们说，我要把这个带回家给扎克。
And this will be ours.
这将是我们的。
And you have it almost 20 years later.
差不多 20 年后你就拥有了它。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
And then I remember Phil and Chris were like, well, did you get the, and I was like, they'll just be like, hey, can I have that sock monkey?
然后我记得菲尔和克里斯说，好吧，你明白了吗，我想，他们会说，嘿，我可以拥有那只袜子猴子吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And I was like, I don't know, like, is that allowed?
我当时想，我不知道，这样可以吗？
And you know, just talking about the sock monkeys, that image.
你知道，只是谈论袜子猴子，那个形象。
And that like we were saying earlier, like that montage, those montages where you hear balance of bastion and see slow dissolves of like candles and sock monkeys, it becomes a sort of weird abstract indie movie for a minute.
就像我们之前说的那样，就像那个蒙太奇，那些你听到堡垒平衡并看到蜡烛和袜子猴子慢慢消失的蒙太奇，它在一分钟内变成了一种奇怪的抽象独立电影。
That was one of those moments.
那就是那些时刻之一。
And I remember this was an episode where we screened it in front of an audience.
我记得这是我们在观众面前放映的一集。
Remember that Courtney?
还记得考特尼吗？
We would screen to get laughs for the first batch of episodes and it played this played great.
我们会筛选第一批剧集以获得笑声，而且播放效果非常棒。
And I remember feeling like it was so haunting, the disappearing sock monkeys to balance of bastion.
我记得感觉就像是令人难以忘怀，消失的袜子猴子到堡垒的平衡。
But then I remember the audience laughed at it.
但后来我记得观众们都笑了。
Like it was all jokes.
好像这一切都是笑话。
And I remember like, you're not supposed to laugh at that part.
我记得，你不应该嘲笑那部分。
This is our touching indie movie moment.
这是我们感人的独立电影时刻。
I was like, angry at the audience for laughing, which is really insane.
我当时想，对观众的笑感到愤怒，这真的很疯狂。
But I will say, I hold on to that montage of hearing Belm Sebastian one of my favorite bands.
但我要说的是，我保留了听到贝尔姆·塞巴斯蒂安（Belm Sebastian）我最喜欢的乐队之一的蒙太奇。
And that song I chose, that's like one of my favorite Belm Sebastian songs we rule the school.
我选择的那首歌，就像我最喜欢的贝尔姆塞巴斯蒂安歌曲之一，我们统治学校。
And that moment of seeing a weird abstract montage, sock monkeys and Belm Sebastian, I was like, we are a different show.
当看到奇怪的抽象蒙太奇、袜子猴和贝尔姆·塞巴斯蒂安的那一刻，我就想，我们是一场不同的表演。
We are a different kind of sitcom.
我们是一种不同类型的情景喜剧。
we don't quite fit on on CBS all the way.
我们一直不太适合 CBS。
Thank God they stuck with us.
感谢上帝，他们一直陪伴着我们。
We were, we were, right?
我们曾经是，我们曾经是，对吧？
We were sandwiched between very different shows on that Monday night comedy lineup.
周一晚上的喜剧阵容中，我们夹在截然不同的节目之间。
None of them were doing balance of action and touching montages with disappearing candles and monkeys and I just remember feeling like this, that's the show.
他们都没有做动作平衡，也没有用消失的蜡烛和猴子做感人的蒙太奇，我只记得这样的感觉，这就是演出。
That's we have to hold onto that feeling.
那就是我们必须保持这种感觉。
That feeling in that little few seconds of film hold onto that like it is gold and don't go, right?
电影中那短短几秒钟的感觉就像金子一样紧紧抓住，不会消失，对吗？
I told Craig this earlier, Courtney, But I remember I loved balance of action.
我早些时候告诉过克雷格，考特尼，但我记得我喜欢行动的平衡。
It was also one of my favorite bands, and I remember reading the script and Feeling like oh my god, I'm on a show that's using a balance of action song as like the central kind of song or theme of the show And I couldn't believe my good fortune that I ended up on a sitcom That would and I really felt like I was in the right I was with my people, you know And when you told me you felt that way I was like I'm so glad we cast Ted as with an actor who loves balance of action And it was one of those, it was, it was, it was, it was us falling in love.
这也是我最喜欢的乐队之一，我记得读过剧本，感觉天哪，我正在参加一个使用平衡动作歌曲作为节目中心歌曲或主题的节目，我不敢相信我的好运，我最终出现在一部情景喜剧中，我真的觉得我是对的，我和我的人民在一起，你知道，当你告诉我你有这种感觉时，我很高兴我们让泰德扮演一个热爱平衡的演员。行动 这是其中之一，它是，它是，它是，这是我们坠入爱河。
Well, the guy who listens to the belt of action is not going to go play laser tag on Saturday night.
好吧，那个听行动带的人不会在周六晚上去玩激光枪战。
Like that was.
就像那样。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
You know, it's, yeah.
你知道，是的。
It really defines, it defines Ted and it defines, it defines what's best about the show.
它确实定义了，它定义了特德，它定义了，它定义了该节目的最佳内容。
Those little moments.
那些小时刻。
And episode four, right?
还有第四集，对吧？
We were still finding it.
我们仍在寻找它。
Those moments early on in the series are like the things you say, okay, that's what our show does.
该系列早期的那些时刻就像你所说的那样，好吧，这就是我们的节目所做的。
Other shows do other things, but our show can do that.
其他节目做其他事情，但我们的节目可以做到。
And I think we'll, as we continue to watch the show, we'll see, oh, you guys really figured this out as we went or figured that out.
我想，当我们继续观看这个节目时，我们会看到，哦，当我们去或弄清楚的时候，你们真的明白了这一点。
But I think for the first four episodes, it's a really impressive batch of opening jousts.
但我认为对于前四集来说，这是一批令人印象深刻的开场角逐。
You know, there was a lot that you guys got right or we got right as a team, you know, and everything that ended up becoming kind of a classic kind of how I met your mother.
你知道，有很多事情你们做对了，或者我们作为一个团队做对了，你知道，所有这些最终都成为我遇见你母亲的经典方式。
like the DNA of it is baked into these first four episodes all day.
就像它的DNA整天融入到前四集中一样。
It really is.
确实如此。
Yeah, it really is.
是的，确实如此。
And I think this one takes a huge credit.
我认为这需要很大的功劳。
I didn't think about this until we started talking today of showing ways that Robin was funny, right?
直到我们今天开始谈论展示罗宾的有趣之处之前我才想到这一点，对吗？
Robin's not just a sought-after perfection and she's not, you know, she's not long for that.
罗宾不仅仅是一个备受追捧的完美主义者，而且她也不是，你知道，她对此并不渴望。
She's, she's the funniest part of that episode in a lot of ways.
从很多方面来说，她都是这一集里最有趣的部分。
She's the comic relief.
她是喜剧演员。
She's the comedic engine of it.
她是这一切的喜剧引擎。
For the first time in series.
系列中首次。
For the first time in series and that's a big deal.
这是系列中的第一次，这是一件大事。
And how great is Kobe?
而科比到底有多伟大呢？
I mean, it's just like she's so hilarious in that episode.
我的意思是，她在那一集中真是太搞笑了。
And she was finding it, she had not done much comedy, coming into this series.
她发现了这一点，她在这个系列中并没有做过太多喜剧。
She had done a lot of other things, but not much comedy.
她还做过很多其他事情，但喜剧不多。
And I think this was the first time where she was like, I get to play.
我想这是她第一次对我说，我可以上场比赛了。
This is a playground.
这是一个游乐场。
I'm taking pratfalls.
我正在犯错误。
I'm smacking my ass online.
我在网上打屁股了。
I'm live on a lab newscast.
我正在直播实验室新闻广播。
She just leaned into it.
她只是倾身进去。
And she was like, okay, I get to do this.
她说，好吧，我得这么做。
And this was the beginning of her finding so, so much talent at comedy.
这就是她发现如此多喜剧天赋的开始。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
She felt like someone found it here.
她感觉好像有人发现了这里。
They felt like someone discovering there.
他们感觉就像有人在那里发现了一样。
They're like, I'll just do my own stunts.
他们就像，我会做我自己的特技。
Like she looked like she was like, I don't need pads.
就像她看起来那样，我不需要护垫。
I'm just gonna do this.
我只是要做这个。
She had a fearlessness about her.
她身上有一种无所畏惧的气质。
Yeah, she was a natural.
是的，她是天生的。
It's so fun to see her find that in this episode.
看到她在这一集中发现这一点真是太有趣了。
Yes, and especially that end moment with the horse carriage driver.
是的，尤其是与马车夫的最后那一刻。
He's so sweet and she's so moved by him and her ability to go from the moved emotional caring and then right into the big pratfall is it's so funny.
他是如此甜蜜，她被他如此感动，她能够从感动的情感关怀，然后直接陷入大失败，这真是太有趣了。
That was, yeah, that was a delight.
是的，那真是令人高兴。
I was gonna say, do you have a favorite memory of the shoot week?
我想说，拍摄周期间你有最美好的回忆吗？
We talked about the writing part.
我们讨论了写作部分。
Does there anything that comes out at you, that night shoot out on the street where she fell?
那天晚上，在她摔倒的那条街上，有什么东西向你发出了声音吗？
Those were always fun.
那些总是很有趣。
That was one of our first night shoots out on the New York street that wasn't like a big romantic Tad giving a great speech or something right it was it's funny because like you know the shows that I had been on that didn't work were traditional sitcoms like you know you're in the bar you're in the apartment and you shoot it yeah and I remember this I remember shooting the balance of bastion stuff like the the you know the sack monkeys like Dave Baker pulling away another sack monkey yeah away another sack monkey and I remember like watching it on the monitor and like having the thought like, can we do this?
那是我们在纽约街头的第一晚拍摄，不像一个大浪漫的泰德发表精彩的演讲或其他正确的事情，这很有趣，因为就像你知道我参加过的那些不起作用的节目是传统的情景喜剧，就像你知道你在酒吧里，你在公寓里，你拍它是的，我记得这个我记得拍摄堡垒之类的东西，比如你知道像戴夫·贝克这样的袋猴把另一只袋猴拉走了是的我记得另一只麻袋猴喜欢在监视器上观看它，并且喜欢这样的想法，我们可以这样做吗？
Like there was like a, can we like, will this work?
就像有一个，我们可以喜欢，这会起作用吗？
Can you do this?
你能做到吗？
And I think that voice sometimes like as a creator, it's, it's so damaging.
我认为这种声音有时就像创作者一样，它是如此具有破坏性。
Like just fucking do it.
就像他妈的就这么做一样。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Yeah, it's so refreshing.
是啊，真是太清爽了。
It's exciting to have a scene where like the call sheet says sock monkey.
有一个场景很令人兴奋，就像宣传单上说的“袜子猴子”。
And there's no askers in the scene.
而且现场没有提问者。
It's just like We didn't need the cast for that part.
就像我们不需要那部分的演员一样。
Yeah.
是的。
I have a crazy story related to this episode.
我有一个与这一集相关的疯狂故事。
And Alec, if this, you can cut this, if it doesn't work.
亚历克，如果这个，你可以把它剪掉，如果它不起作用。
But, so Annie Doodak and I who played Natalie, we became very good friends.
但是，安妮·杜达克和我扮演娜塔莉，我们成为了非常好的朋友。
And one time I wanted to go to Venice to buy this painting for my friend Jesse who was opening a new business and he loved this painting.
有一次我想去威尼斯给我的朋友杰西买这幅画，他正在开一家新店，他很喜欢这幅画。
So Annie came with me.
于是安妮就跟我一起来了。
I was gonna buy her brunch.
我本来想给她买早午餐。
If she came with me to buy this painting, we met the artist.
如果她和我一起去买这幅画，我们就见到了这位艺术家。
She ended up truly marrying this artist.
她最终真正嫁给了这位艺术家。
She ended up marrying the guy that I took her to.
她最终嫁给了我带她去的那个人。
They're no longer married, but they have two, I think, beautiful children.
他们不再结婚了，但我认为他们有两个漂亮的孩子。
And this artist, Matthew Heller, told me, he said, what are you working on?
这位艺术家马修·海勒告诉我，他说，你在做什么？
I said, I'm on the show how I made my mother because I actually ended up, I had known him weirdly.
我说，我在节目中讲述了我是如何造就我母亲的，因为我最终发现，我对他的认识很奇怪。
And he said, oh, your set designer has one of my paintings on your set.
他说，哦，你的布景设计师在你的布景里放了我的一幅画。
I think it's in the apartment.
我认为是在公寓里。
Oh wow.
哦哇。
And that painting on the mantle, What is the skyline like is it a?
还有地幔上的那幅画，天际线是什么样的？
No, it's like an abstract.
不，这就像一个摘要。
It's kind of like red and orange.
有点像红色和橙色。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
I could point it out But that's just one of this painter Matthew Heller who I took to meet Annie and then they reconnected and then they ended up being married for many years So I thought that was pretty wild.
我可以指出，但这只是我带他去见安妮的画家马修·海勒之一，然后他们重新联系起来，然后他们最终结婚了很多年，所以我认为这非常疯狂。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, there's a bunch of that on how I met your mother There's a bunch of weird synergy and like there's like little destiny thing like what the show is about sort of manifested within the making of the show in some ways And Josh, we would never cut that.
是的，有很多关于我如何认识你母亲的事情，有很多奇怪的协同作用，就像有一些命运的事情，就像这部剧的内容在某种程度上在这部剧的制作中以某种方式体现出来一样，乔希，我们永远不会删掉这一点。
That's how that guy's kids met, how he met that guy's kids and that's right.
那个人的孩子就是这样认识的，他也是这样认识那个人的孩子的，没错。
That's right.
这是正确的。
That's a very on-brand.
这是一个非常有品牌的。
Yeah.
是的。
It connects to my Courtney saying of like her whole life from when you wrote this episode, I forgot that you got engaged literally right before it aired, that's amazing.
这与我考特尼的说法有关，从你写这一集时起，她的一生就开始了，我忘了你在播出前就订婚了，这太棒了。
You, like from your first episode you wrote to 200 eight later, you know, whatever your last one in season nine was, like our lives kept happening during the nine years of this show, and all the while we were taking things from these new chapters of our lives and putting them in there in real time, because we were the same age as the actors.
你，就像从你写的第一集到八年后的200集一样，你知道，无论你在第九季的最后一集是什么，就像我们的生活在这部剧的九年里一直在发生，而我们一直在从我们生活的这些新篇章中获取东西并实时地将它们放在那里，因为我们和演员同龄。
And it's sort of like, right, you had kids.
这有点像，对，你有孩子了。
And you're like, now you're pitching jokes and astray ideas about being a mom.
你就像，现在你在讲关于做妈妈的笑话和错误的想法。
And this was like a career as, you know, you were mining things from your struggle part of your career to put into the Robin story in this episode.
这就像一个职业，你知道，你从你职业生涯的奋斗部分中挖掘一些东西，并将其放入本集中的罗宾故事中。
It's just interesting how in real time all of that was.
有趣的是，这一切都是实时发生的。
We were really mining our lives and living them just right alongside, we're like a few steps ahead of the characters.
我们真的在挖掘我们的生活，并与它们一起生活，我们就像比角色领先了几步。
You and I both, right, because I had to go, we both had kids and like it just was interesting how we were kind of almost transcribing our lives up to the minute onto this TV show.
你和我，对吧，因为我必须离开，我们都有孩子，我们几乎把我们的生活抄录到这个电视节目上，这很有趣。
Courtney, I have a question for you.
考特尼，我有个问题要问你。
Since you were on from basically day one until the final day, did you, did you feel some like special deeper connection with the show?
既然你基本上从第一天一直到最后一天，你是否感觉与这部剧有某种更深层次的联系？
Like did you feel like some, not quite, I don't know if the word is ownership, But like, what was it like to just be there from day one to the final day?
就像你觉得有些，不完全是，我不知道这个词是否是所有权，但是，就像，从第一天到最后一天都在那里是什么感觉？
Because I remember you and I had a really sweet moment on the very last day you just came up and you said some lovely things to me and I'll never forget that.
因为我记得你和我在最后一天度过了一段非常甜蜜的时刻，你刚刚过来，对我说了一些可爱的事情，我永远不会忘记。
And I'm just curious, like, what was it like for you when you look back at the whole kind of decade?
我只是很好奇，当你回顾这整个十年时，你感觉如何？
You know, it honestly, it was such a gift.
你知道，老实说，这是一份礼物。
Like, I mean, Craig knows this.
就像，我的意思是，克雷格知道这一点。
Like, you know, when you're a writer and you're trying to like get your shit together, your agents, you know, you would read all the pilots.
就像，你知道，当你是一名作家并且你试图把你的狗屎整理在一起时，你的经纪人，你知道，你会读所有的试播集。
And I read this pilot and I was like, I called Lee Sharon Agent Craig and I.
我读了这个试播集，然后我就打电话给李莎伦特工克雷格和我。
And I called my agent and I was like, I am obsessed with this show.
我打电话给我的经纪人，我说，我对这个节目很着迷。
Like I, I love this.
像我一样，我喜欢这个。
I think it's so true.
我认为这是真的。
I felt like it really spoke to like something I felt.
我觉得它确实说出了我的感受。
Once again, it goes back to like, I am these characters, like these are my friends.
再一次，它又回到了喜欢，我就是这些角色，就像这些是我的朋友一样。
Like this is what we're going through.
就像这就是我们正在经历的事情。
And I was like, I really feel like there's a real thing that were presented this idea that all guys are players and they wanna just be out there having sex.
我当时想，我真的觉得有一个真实的东西提出了这个想法，即所有男人都是玩家，他们只想在那里做爱。
And it's like, no, the guys, I know are like good guys who wanna find love.
就好像，不，我知道这些人都是想要寻找爱情的好人。
And the girls are all like, we're in the sex in the city now.
女孩们都说，我们现在在城市里做爱。
But yeah, yeah.
但是是的，是的。
There was like a shift happen, yeah, yeah, totally.
好像发生了转变，是的，是的，完全如此。
Yeah, there was like, we had the women are in the sex in the city part, but we didn't have the men are looking to settle down.
是的，就像，我们让女性在城市里做爱，但我们没有让男性想要安定下来。
point of view, and I was so passionate about it that like, I really did harass my agent who I think in turn harassed me in Carter.
我对此非常热衷，以至于我确实骚扰了我的经纪人，我认为他反过来又骚扰了我的卡特。
I remember feeling very confident in the pilot, because I'm like, I don't know who this Courtney woman is, but she really wants to be on this fucking show.
我记得我对试播集感到非常有信心，因为我想，我不知道这个考特尼女人是谁，但她真的很想参加这个他妈的节目。
I remember feeling, and I remember feeling like it must be good because she's hunting it down.
我记得我的感觉，我记得感觉这一定很好，因为她正在寻找它。
And you really were, now Courtney, tell, I think this is when this line was said, our shared agent Matt Rice, one of the greats, what, when you were so excited about the pilot, and I mean, really wrestled in true elbows to get in the room for a meeting with us when the show was getting picked up.
现在，考特尼，告诉你，我想这就是说这句话的时候，我们共同的经纪人马特·赖斯，一位伟大的人，当你对试播集感到如此兴奋时，我的意思是，在节目开始播出时，真的竭尽全力进入房间与我们会面。
What didn't Matt Rice?
马特·赖斯没有做到什么？
What was Matt Rice's advice to you when you before you came to the meeting with me and Carter?
在你来参加我和卡特的会议之前，马特·赖斯给你的建议是什么？
Am I getting this right?
我说得对吗？
You know what I mean, yeah?
你知道我的意思，是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
What did he say?
他说什么？
You gotta say.
你得说。
Because it became a catchphrase in the writer's room.
因为它成了作家房间里的流行语。
For a long time.
许久。
It became a catchphrase.
这成为了一个流行语。
And he was like, Kang, our agent is amazing.
他说，康，我们的经纪人太棒了。
Like I love him.
就像我爱他一样。
He's like, he's like, amfing me up.
他就像，他就像，让我兴奋起来。
He's like, Kang, it's gonna be awesome.
他说，康，这会很棒。
I'm like, get in there.
我想，进去吧。
Like show your enthusiasm, don't hold back, tell them how much you love this, have your jokes ready, be amped up.
比如表现出你的热情，不要退缩，告诉他们你有多喜欢这个，准备好你的笑话，兴奋起来。
I mean, don't Courtney Kang all over the place.
我的意思是，不要到处都是 Courtney Kang。
Don't Courtney Kang all over the place.
不要到处都是 Courtney Kang。
And I was like, wait, wait, what's, what's, what's, what's Courtney Kang all over the place?
我当时想，等等，等等，考特尼·康到处都是什么，什么，什么，什么？
Okay, all over the place.
好吧，到处都是。
And then I, oh, I think we were in the meeting, we started talking or something.
然后我，哦，我想我们正在开会，我们开始交谈什么的。
And somehow we started talking about, like, NC Hammer, the typewriter.
不知何故，我们开始谈论 NC Hammer、打字机等。
And I think some, what, like, Carter's, and I was like, was like, what's that?
我想有些人，比如卡特的，我当时想，那是什么？
And so I, like, jump up and I start doing that, like, NC Hammer, like, top typewriter.
所以我，就像，跳起来，我开始这样做，就像，NC Hammer，就像，顶级打字机。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And it's right as I'm, like, this point, I was like, oh, this is Courtney Cainey.
这是对的，就像我一样，在这一点上，我当时想，哦，这是考特尼·凯尼。
I love this.
我喜欢这个。
We love you, Courtney, we're so happy you were able to join us.
我们爱你，考特尼，我们很高兴你能够加入我们。
I got married last year, And my wife has never seen how I met your mother.
我去年结婚了，我妻子从来没有见过我是怎么认识你妈妈的。
So that was part of the impetus for doing this show was she really wanted to watch it and fill in this chapter of my life that she never got to witness.
所以这是做这个节目的部分动力，因为她真的很想看它并填补我生命中她从未见证过的这一章。
So we were watching it together and we have a segment that we don't have an acronym for it yet.
所以我们一起观看了它，我们有一个片段还没有缩写。
But it's something like questions and observations from a psychologist and relationship expert who's never seen how I met your mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
但这就像一位心理学家和关系专家的问题和观察，他从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而你母亲恰好也嫁给了乔什。
Something like that.
类似的事情。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
Yeah.
是的。
Right, Ronald's off the tongue.
是的，罗纳德已经说不出话了。
Exactly.
确切地。
We wanted something pithy.
我们想要一些简洁的东西。
So she's sometimes will just tell me what her question is.
所以她有时只会告诉我她的问题是什么。
Sometimes she'll record a voice memo.
有时她会录制语音备忘录。
I have not even heard this one.
我什至没有听说过这个。
I just sent it to Alec, but I don't know what this is.
我刚把它发给 Alec，但我不知道这是什么。
So let's hear it.
那么让我们听听吧。
I think this episode touches upon one of the age-old questions regarding romantic love.
我认为这一集触及了有关浪漫爱情的古老问题之一。
Is this the wrong person, or is it just the wrong time?
是错的人，还是只是错的时间？
I hear patients ponder this frequently.
我经常听到患者思考这个问题。
I think most of us have come across that issue with someone we've dated at one point or another, but I'm wondering as artists, if maybe you also have this with creative projects, so my question is, what is your return of the shirt if you're willing to share with an idea, a concept, or a script that didn't work out in the moment, but you fantasize could potentially work now.
我想我们大多数人都曾与曾经约会过的人遇到过这个问题，但我想知道作为艺术家，你是否也有这样的创意项目，所以我的问题是，如果你愿意分享一个想法、一个概念或一个目前不可行的脚本，但你幻想现在可能可行，那么你会返回什么衬衫。
Wow.
哇。
That's a mind blowing question.
这是一个令人兴奋的问题。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I think that is a true theme of the episode.
嗯，我认为这是这一集的真正主题。
It's like, you mentioned this actually, like I've changed maybe my perspective on this relationship change.
就像，你实际上提到了这一点，就像我已经改变了，也许我对这段关系的看法发生了变化。
She changed because certainly, I mean, you hear stories all the time like we dated in college and it was disaster and we reconnected in our mid 30s and it was great.
她改变了，因为当然，我的意思是，你总是听到我们在大学约会的故事，那是一场灾难，我们在 30 多岁的时候重新联系起来，这真是太棒了。
You know, and I think that's what Ted is holding out for.
你知道，我认为这就是特德所坚持的目的。
But I think Jordan has a question around creativity like I don't know if you guys are the same way, but I always have so many tabs open Like I have so many projects that are kind of in various stages of completion or disarray and Sometimes something is just sitting there half-formed and it just won't catch fire and other times something that was sitting there I'll be re-inspired and it'll just the heat will be there and I'll and I'll be able to finish it and maybe make it and I think sometimes like I try to honor honor the piece of art or the script or the song as having its own kind of arc and intelligence and knowledge about when it's going to be ready.
但我认为乔丹对创造力有一个疑问，就像我不知道你们是否也有同样的想法，但我总是打开很多选项卡就像我有很多项目处于不同的完成阶段或混乱状态有时有些东西只是半成型，它只是不会着火而其他时候有些东西坐在那里我会重新受到启发，它会只是热量会在那里，我和我将能够完成它，也许会成功，我想有时就像我试图尊重一件艺术品、剧本或歌曲，因为它有自己的弧线、智慧和关于何时准备好的知识。
So I really try to be in dialogue with the thing like, are you ready to open up to me, or am I ready to put the work in on this?
所以我真的尝试与诸如此类的事情进行对话，你准备好向我敞开心扉了吗？或者我准备好为此付出努力了吗？
So I've had things that have sat around for a while.
所以我有些东西已经搁置了一段时间了。
I just finished the last song from my album that I'm recording now.
我刚刚完成了我现在正在录制的专辑中的最后一首歌。
I started it on my honeymoon in April.
我在四月份度蜜月时开始了它。
And it was just I would write like a first a month, you know, like, and other songs you sit down and they're, they're done in 20 minutes, like, but I, I, I really try to honor the thing and let it be.
只是我会像每月第一首一样写，你知道，就像，还有其他歌曲，你坐下来，它们在 20 分钟内完成，就像，但我，我，我真的尽力尊重这件事并顺其自然。
But I, I don't, I don't throw anything away because I feel like there might be a day where it calls me back.
但我，我不，我不会扔掉任何东西，因为我觉得也许有一天它会召唤我回来。
And the debate is always, is it a good idea to go back?
争论始终是，回去是个好主意吗？
It's very much from the show because sometimes you go back to an idea and you have 10 to the moment Ted has of, dear God, I've got to get out of this.
这很大程度上来自于节目，因为有时你会回到一个想法，而你有 10 个想法，直到 Ted 的那一刻，亲爱的上帝，我必须摆脱这个。
Why did I go that totally?
为什么我完全这么做了？
Or you remember, you remember why you got stuck and threw it away or stopped working on it.
或者你记得，你记得为什么你被卡住并扔掉它或停止工作。
Yeah, you know, that would happen all the time in the room.
是的，你知道，这种事在房间里一直会发生。
Like, we would be like, oh, we had an idea about, you know, the gang goes to the mall.
就像，我们会说，哦，我们有一个想法，你知道，这帮人去购物中心。
Oh, yeah, there was all this great stuff.
哦，是的，有这么多很棒的东西。
There was all this stuff.
那里有所有这些东西。
And then you pull up the notes and it was like, the gang goes to the mall and was like, that's what we had.
然后你拿出笔记，就像，这伙人去了商场，然后就像，这就是我们所拥有的。
Was it more?
还多吗？
You remember it sort of more fun.
你记得它更有趣。
Yeah, we were ready to shrink that mall thing down to just a fake pop song by a Canadian pop Yeah, it's true.
是的，我们已经准备好将商场的事情缩小为一首加拿大流行音乐的假流行歌曲是的，这是真的。
That feeling of going back to the room notes of something, and you go, like, that was excellent.
回到房间记下一些东西的感觉，然后你就走了，那真是太棒了。
That was cool.
太酷了。
This is going to catch fire.
这会着火的。
And you sit there for a whole day.
然后你就坐在那里一整天。
And it's basically, I've got to get out of this.
基本上，我必须摆脱这个困境。
I've got to.
我必须这么做。
And there isn't energy to these things.
这些东西没有能量。
There isn't energy.
没有能量。
And things have a time.
事情都有一个时间。
I agree completely, Josh.
我完全同意，乔什。
I've gotten very, like, woo, woo, about creative stuff, way of the two.
我对创意的东西非常感兴趣，两者兼而有之。
It's like, there's a time you shouldn't have to force it too much.
就像，有时候你不应该强迫太多。
If something calls you back, you have to be honest.
如果有什么事情给你回电，你必须诚实。
Do you want to go back to that thing?
你想回到那件事吗？
And Ted was not, it was yet again in this episode.
特德没有，这一集又出现了。
Ted was not honest with himself.
特德对自己并不诚实。
He just wanted the shortcut to feeling like, and she'll be the one, and she'll be answering.
他只是想要找到一种感觉的捷径，而她就是那个人，她会回答。
He's rushing, and he was not honest with himself about it.
他太匆忙了，而且他对自己并不诚实。
And I think there is a parallel between relationships and art where, I think there's this very American idea of like, relationships are work.
我认为关系和艺术之间有相似之处，我认为有一种非常美国的观念，即关系就是工作。
They require work and art requires work.
他们需要工作，艺术也需要工作。
And you got a grind away and grind away and work, work, work.
然后你就开始苦苦工作、工作、工作。
And I actually think that effortlessness is undervalued in both relationships and art.
事实上，我认为在人际关系和艺术中，轻松的价值都被低估了。
Like, we've all caught a wave, where writing just feels like our fingers are being moved rather than we're moving them, where you really feel like something's just, you're capturing it, it's just coming through you.
就像，我们都经历过一种浪潮，写作时感觉就像我们的手指在移动，而不是我们在移动它们，你真的感觉有些东西只是，你正在捕捉它，它只是通过你而来。
And in the same way, I struggled in relationships for so long and it really did feel like work.
同样地，我在人际关系中挣扎了很长时间，这确实感觉像是在工作。
And then I still have work with my wife.
然后我和我妻子还有工作。
It's still, you still have to put forth the effort, you have to apologize when you screwed up all these things.
不过，你还是要付出努力，把这些事情搞砸了，你还得道歉。
But there is a kind of ease and effortlessness when I, when I'm with her that feels new and different and like kind of what I was looking for without being able to even say that at the time because I didn't know that.
但是，当我和她在一起时，我有一种轻松和轻松的感觉，感觉是新的、不同的，就像我一直在寻找的东西，但当时甚至无法说出来，因为我不知道这一点。
Well, Josh, Jordan never gets upset at you.
好吧，乔什，乔丹永远不会生你的气。
She now knows she can go watch a lot of footage of you getting the shit kicked out of you, starting with episode four.
她现在知道她可以去看很多你被踢出屎的镜头，从第四集开始。
We're trying to shirt.
我们正在尝试穿衬衫。
She's like, I'm a little pissed at Josh.
她说，我对乔希有点生气。
I'm like, why do you have a montage of Ted most beginning to be beaten up.
我想，为什么你有一个泰德刚开始被殴打的蒙太奇。
So after our launch yesterday, we received incredible messages from all around the world.
因此，昨天发布后，我们收到了来自世界各地的令人难以置信的消息。
They came to us from my newsletter or sub-stack page, from the Oomium sub-stack page, from Instagram at how we made your mother, and from our website.
他们通过我的时事通讯或子堆栈页面、Oomium 子堆栈页面、Instagram 上的“我们如何创造了你的母亲”以及我们的网站找到了我们。
And we're reading them all, and we're so grateful to everyone for taking the time to tell us what how I met your mother means to you.
我们正在阅读所有这些内容，我们非常感谢大家花时间告诉我们我如何认识你母亲对你意味着什么。
This one is from Amy, and it was a response to the sub-stack that I wrote on my newsletter.
这是艾米发来的，是对我在时事通讯上写的子堆栈的回应。
And she writes, the show came out the year after I first got married and had my second child.
她写道，这部剧在我结婚并生下第二个孩子的第二年就播出了。
But it took a few years for me to watch.
但我花了几年时间才看完。
First watch was when Netflix still did Mail DVDs, LOL.
第一次观看是在 Netflix 还在制作邮件 DVD 的时候，哈哈。
The characters were the exact age I was, slash AM in all the years that happened, loved that.
这些角色的年龄正是我的年龄，在所有发生的事情中都是斜线AM，喜欢这一点。
In my late teens, early 20s, I was a friends fan, watched with my mom, and even got to go to set there at one point, but they were 10 years older than me, so hymnium solidified more with me.
在我十几岁、20岁出头的时候，我是朋友们的粉丝，和我妈妈一起观看，甚至一度去那里拍摄，但他们比我大10岁，所以赞美诗对我来说更加牢固。
There's so much realism philosophy in it.
里面有很多现实主义哲学。
My best friend, who's 10 years younger than me, loves it as well.
我最好的朋友，比我小10岁，也喜欢它。
And one example of the greatness slash realism, she often brings up is the one curly fry, LOL.
她经常提到的伟大斜线现实主义的一个例子是一条卷发，哈哈。
We both are huge romantics like Ted, but we've been through some rough relationships and had to realize we had some codependent issues.
我们俩都是像泰德一样的浪漫主义者，但我们经历过一些艰难的关系，不得不意识到我们有一些相互依赖的问题。
And other things we've worked out in therapy and Coda groups shout out to Coda and therapy.
我们在治疗和 Coda 团体中解决的其他问题也向 Coda 和治疗大喊大叫。
So that has changed some perspective on the characters and things on the show but doesn't make us love it any less.
所以这改变了我们对剧中人物和事物的一些看法，但并没有让我们减少对它的喜爱。
The show is cathartic.
这个节目是宣泄的。
It's a night watch still.
依然是守夜。
Sometimes I go from the first episode to the last but often I let Alexa or Siri choose a number of the season and for the season in episode.
有时我会从第一集跳到最后一集，但我经常让 Alexa 或 Siri 选择季节的编号以及剧集中的季节。
Sometimes I go to a specific episode if I need to think back on something or process some feelings.
有时，如果我需要回想某些事情或处理某些感受，我会去看特定的剧集。
I choreographed a yellow umbrella ballet a lobby on Rose last year.
去年我在罗斯酒店的大厅里编排了一部黄色雨伞芭蕾舞剧。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
I've danced to your songs.
我曾随着你的歌起舞。
Can you send up a clip of that?
你能把那个片段发过来吗？
Please send us a clip of that.
请给我们发送一个剪辑。
I've danced to your songs and many other pivotal songs from the show.
我随着你的歌曲和节目中的许多其他关键歌曲跳舞。
I have pop culture, him, you reminders, peppered throughout my house, shower curtains, earrings, pictures.
我有流行文化，他，你提醒一下，我的房子里到处都是，浴帘，耳环，图片。
I never don't cry a **** for the **** Robyn saying **** the speech Ted gives **** before **** because so often I've wanted to time travel or skip ahead to adjust things.
我从来不会因为****罗宾说****泰德在****之前发表****演讲而哭泣，因为我常常想进行时间旅行或跳过来调整事情。
Though ultimately they happen as they should.
尽管最终它们会如期发生。
All just so relatable.
一切都是如此相关。
I've always been fascinated with the subject of fate, destiny, free will.
我一直对命运、命运、自由意志的主题着迷。
There's private reasons about who I watched the show with that also tie me to my love of the show.
我和谁一起看这部剧有一些私人原因，这也让我对这部剧的热爱联系在一起。
It just is different than any other show, and we'll always have a huge place of comfort and love in my heart.
它与任何其他节目不同，我们将永远在我心中占据一个巨大的安慰和爱的地方。
Thank you, Amy.
谢谢你，艾米。
That's so.
就是这样。
Thank you, Amy.
谢谢你，艾米。
Lovely.
迷人的。
So nice.
真好。
And honestly, please do send us the footage of that dance you were going on.
老实说，请务必将您正在进行的舞蹈的片段发送给我们。
Yeah, I'd be really happy.
是的，我真的会很高兴。
And if you're listening, if you want to get your voice on the podcast, we'd love to hear from you go to how we made your mother dot com go to contact and record your actual voice and tell us what how we made your mother means to you.
如果您正在收听，如果您想在播客上发出自己的声音，我们很乐意听您讲述我们如何让您的母亲网络联系并录制您的真实声音，并告诉我们我们如何让您的母亲对您意味着什么。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lem, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lem 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, artwork by John Marrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Marrow 设计。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯，阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死亡父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下得以实现，营销由 Tink Media 提供。
will in fact dance.
事实上会跳舞。